One of the beautiful things about the Internet is you could watch a video,
meet someone from that video and have them in the podcast online right now.
Chris Harris,
ladies and gentlemen,
you're one of my all time favorite auto journalists,
you and Jeremy Clarkson because both you and Matt Farah,
the both of you guys,
you and Jeremy Clarkson,
a really funny,
you know,
you,
you say some really funny shit while you driving these cars around your you and
also you're also like very obviously a true car nut.
You really love cars.
They all have a sort of medical condition with cards ready.
It's a problem.
I was just talking to someone earlier about this and um,
if you look at the upsides of what I do for living,
which is basically to review cars,
well that's how it started out.
And it's something a bit different.
I already,
um,
I get free cars.
That's the upside,
right?
So I can,
I can basically earn not much money.
That's what you do as,
and also journalists,
do you have a a line in earning,
not much money,
but if you want to borrow a gt three for the weekend,
you've Fernet portion along.
As you can justify it,
you probably the cost,
you get lots of free cars,
really expensive,
nice cars.
So what you shouldn't do is buy cars,
but I still buy cars.
I got too many cars and I don't have much money.
But yeah,
it's with your family.
Did you get shit about that?
I don't know.
I have a long suffering,
an understanding wife who,
who sort of sees it and actually the car market at the moment,
it's pretty good as you know.
So there's stuff that I bought at the top that I bought has kind of gone up a
bit or that it's all on paper and I'm sure that by the time you've sure and it's
broken down,
you've serviced it at,
you probably wipe out all the upsides anyway.
Um,
but no.
Yeah,
I,
it's a great subject,
is a great medium to work with you.
And it's no coincidence that top gear such success because the guys are
brilliant.
They're super talented,
and if you put them in charge of a gardening show,
it'd be just as good.
Well,
those guys made a shit load of money though.
They really did make a lot of money.
I mean,
they're wealthy.
Yeah.
I mean it's not past tense.
They're still doing it.
Yeah.
And um,
yeah,
they've,
they've done a fantastic job,
but then,
you know,
that is globally the largest television show per views in the world is,
it really isn't that amazing.
Cars.
Yeah.
So yeah,
the top gift phenomena is,
is amazing.
I get asked about it the whole time,
but that's it.
I love it.
And I celebrate it and I think they're brilliant at what they do.
But that's a bit like finishing the Olympic 200 meters and being the bloat that
comes second and being asked what it was like to watch Usain Bolt's ass.
You know,
it's kind of,
it's,
uh,
I want to celebrate it,
but it's,
it's quite frustrating because they dominate the market.
Like no other genre has a dominance like that.
So if you,
if you view television as a series of verticals,
you know,
gardening,
cookery,
martial arts,
whatever you want it to be,
motoring is,
is the one that has the fewest players.
And the biggest dominance,
I mean,
if it was a company,
it would be investigated by the monopolies and mergers commission and shut down.
So,
but you know,
we were [inaudible] I had someone at MIP calm trying to sell my wares.
You know,
there's MIP comes the big content fairing can,
where you want to buy a television program about anything.
You can buy it.
And I thought,
we need to make some money out this content that send someone down there and
sell some.
And they read.
And you can buy three British TV programs about baking alone,
but you can't actually,
you know,
you,
you can't find many car shows.
There aren't many out there actually in Europe.
Certainly.
I know you've got some here,
but they're all quite tangental the cars one was coincidental,
but we have top gear,
u s we have a version with a good buddy of mine,
Adam Ferrara's on,
they're doing like a version of,
and it's so,
I mean I love Adam,
he's a great guy,
but they're copying it in some weird way where they even do the thing where
they're standing around and they have an audience that's standing around them
exactly the same as they do in the UK.
Yeah.
I'm the one thing we've always set out to do is to never copy top gear.
It's ludicrous.
It's like sitting down to write a novel and saying,
I'm going to try and copy bleak house.
Either you're not going to do it right,
it's going to go wrong.
So I think,
yeah,
copying the format,
it's impossible because the format they've arrived at and they've arrived at
because of the personalities they have and the chemistry that you have and it
works,
but if you're not absolutely on point,
I think it's difficult to pull it off.
Really.
Does Jimmy?
It's Jeremy Clarkson.
Did he take any more shit for that?
You know,
he did that eeny meeny miny moe thing where he did the racist,
well I think,
um,
I think all of that was just unfortunate really.
And uh,
and he's probably dealt with it and taking his pain.
But then the big one that just kicked off with the Argentina one you had to
know,
have you heard about that?
No.
Of Gold.
Where do I start with that?
That's become a proper diplomatic incident.
Obviously my cup,
my country UK doesn't have a great relationship with Argentina cause we had a
bit of a war with them in 1992 over the Falkland Islands and Mal Venus,
I think they called them.
And they feel quite strongly that we should give them back.
And I think we feel that the inhabitants probably should be allowed to,
uh,
have a democratic say in that.
And they sort of want to remain British.
I gather I remain nonpartisan and all of this,
I don't really know.
Okay.
And actually,
um,
so long story short,
they've just filmed the Christmas special.
They took three cars,
I Think v eight sports cars and they're going to drive them all the way down
through South America and ended up in Argentina I think.
And if you've not heard about this,
this is so ridiculous.
It's very interesting because this is big.
This has been big news in the UK and in Argentina.
Um,
and when I tell you the story and why it kicked off,
I want to see your reaction and your reaction because,
because you might just turn around and go,
that is nonsense.
You couldn't make that up.
So they bought,
I think Alexis is a Spree v eight to drive through South America.
I mean you couldn't get between London and Bristol in one of those that are
breaking down.
And they bought a Porsche nine to eight gt and they bought some kind of Ford
Mustang fastback,
seventies one I think.
And halfway through the Philippines they had to remove them plates on the push
because it,
the number plate was accused of having some kind of a reference to the Falkland
Islands.
It was a totally,
it was a normal British number plate.
So it had a number three letters.
So it's so a letter,
three numbers and three letters afterwards and it was something like j nine
eight two for that little light,
1982 and then f k l Falklands.
But you know,
it was,
it was a bit like me looking at your number plate and just using it as an
anagram of nothing and just making up the fact that you were calling me a tepee
Uranian or something and I'd just,
so anyhow,
uh,
full diplomatic incident occurred and they somehow someone on social media or,
or the,
the,
the information of that number plate was disseminated in us in Argentina when
they were down there shooting and they got a fence.
Effectively a mob came after them.
It's like throwing rocks at the cars.
They were told they were told to leave the country and they did and they
basically had to run pretty much as the,
as the crew tallit for their lives.
So they abandoned the cars,
which just got smashed up.
They left this town.
They had to nip across the board,
I think in the Chile to get out of the place and they flew back with that
finishing the show.
Um,
and it's really kicked off.
So the Argentinian embassy has made a formal complaint to the BBC saying it
shouldn't add the program.
Um,
and it's all around this number plate.
Well,
the number plate came with the car pretty much.
I mean if you,
if you trace the number plate back,
that's,
that's the number plate the car had and they've just drawn a conclusion from it.
However,
the question that is asked is,
does Jeremy have the wit and naughtiness about him to identify a number plate in
advance and then choose that car because of that number plate and then go out
and shoot a whole program around it just so he can poke some fun at the
Argentinians.
Um,
now I,
I think that's so far fetched that even a comedy genius like Jeremy Isn't,
isn't,
isn't going to be able to do that.
So,
um,
but it really has kicked off and it's quite an ugly incident.
That seems completely ridiculous.
Yeah.
I mean,
I know,
they were rocks with throne.
Someone got injured,
they had to leave you equipment,
got lost,
the cars got a band and they just left the cars and rant.
That's so crazy.
That doesn't make any sense at all.
No.
So I've just told you the story as a casual bystander.
Does that just sound ridiculous to you?
Sounds completely ridiculous.
But it,
unless it's like Falkland Suck.
You know,
which remember when they did the one through America and they just,
and they,
and they and Kamins car had I love man love painted down the side of it or
something and they try and they shit.
Well they'd know they drove through some Bible belt state and they got chased
off a petro full call.
Fairly aggressive fashion.
It's a very good one.
Um,
I love man love.
Yes.
I thought,
Oh man,
love rocks or something.
What?
Stay with it.
I don't know,
but it was somewhere where such things and not appreciated.
Well,
the United States is,
we have some differences.
You know,
if you did that in California,
nobody would give a shit if he did it in New York,
most likely no one will give a shit.
But if you went to Tennessee and you drove around,
there's certain places where you could get in trouble with anything.
You've remotely controversial,
remotely supporting of homosexuality or in remotely in any way,
negative towards the Bible or negative towards Christianity.
Yeah,
we've got some knuckle draggers.
It's an interesting group of knuckle draggers in this country.
Everyone has a right to their own opinion.
I'm not gonna say anymore than that.
I want to make it to the airport safety without being beaten up by so much.
You're fine,
man.
You're in La.
This is as far west as it gets.
This is the,
the last outpost before you hit the ocean.
Yeah,
it does seem pretty,
pretty laid back here.
This is very laid back and very progressive.
This is the most progressive part of the country for sure.
Yeah.
This in San Francisco,
San Francisco,
almost to progressive cause they go so far left.
They almost become right with their lefty ideas,
like they get so socialist,
you know,
so so progressive that they,
they're like Uber supportive of marginalized people to the point where it
becomes imbalanced but that's necessary.
It counter bound.
I think all in all it balances out.
Like you take a little bit of a,
you know,
Tennessee or Kentucky and you balance it out with Oakland or Berkeley and it all
comes together.
I think my modern democracies in the same aren't they?
And certainly the European ideal tends to lean towards what you've described to
San Francisco.
You can,
you can,
as a sort of minority myself within my country,
you can start to support minorities to the point where actually you,
you d normalize the normal and then,
and then everyone's standing around going,
well,
what's going on here?
You know,
sh,
sh what,
where do,
where do you draw the line?
I read in the news today that the European Union or the European law has just
decided to,
to classify obesity as a,
as a medical condition,
which is very interesting situation.
Not that I know much about it,
but it's probably endemic of what's going on.
But you know,
okay.
Some people genetically just pile on the weight.
I do.
So,
yeah.
And I feel very sort of people that do.
But if you just happen to be a fat fucker,
there eats loads of burgers.
I don't really see why I should have to support the fact that you eat burgers.
Oh,
so medical condition meaning that like you have socialized medicine so that that
helps us pick.
In the UK we have something called the welfare state,
which is,
you know,
quite foreign to some people.
The doll.
Well,
yeah,
you have the rock and roll though.
And um,
and,
and I feel as a,
as I sort of closet socialist at times,
I feel quite strongly about that.
I think if you,
if you earn a good amount of money and you have a surplus from it,
once you've had a good time,
we'd get money,
then why shouldn't that go towards people that are less fortunate than you?
That's a good thing.
Why shouldn't you try and have free healthcare sensibly?
As long as the money's spent on doctors and not middle management,
that's all.
That's all great.
But if you choose,
you know,
I've just had something called a fat burger earlier.
Oh,
you went to fat Burger and I'd never been on tour right over here then it was,
it was down near Jay's,
Gary's Jay Leno's carriage.
And um,
and I,
I just looked at the pictures on the wall and when hit the bloat,
when just have a large,
I'm an encore hungry,
I'll have the one in the middle of the one,
like the,
not the biggest,
but the one down.
That's what I'd normally do in the UK.
And this bloke basically served me a cow that had been through a mincer and
slapped between two bits of bread.
And I just looked at the fucking thing.
Um,
and I,
of course I ate the whole thing.
So now I feel genuinely ill if I channel on your desk.
I'm sorry,
but you're fucking around with burgers though.
And you're in the United States.
Have you eaten it in and out?
Yeah,
of course.
I have been.
I've been in,
I've been in the country since Monday.
I've had two in announced.
You can't,
this is,
you've got to get a three by three.
You got to get an in and out,
three by three with raw onions.
But this is the one to the counts.
So I love the concept of a retail outfit,
the cells,
false food.
That doesn't tell you what you can buy a pack,
animal style under the counselor.
It's a bit like when you were back in the days of Vhs,
you go to the video shop and go to the guy when the cancer can have something
fun to the counts of how you play man under the counter.
It's the same isn't it?
Like someone said,
you have your fries,
animal style.
I'm looking at this.
Nothing about animal slide up there.
Just to come back to that point.
I think,
yeah,
I think that kind of,
that sorts of socialism works,
but I,
I struggle with the idea of paying for people who just eat too much food.
I agree.
I mean I socialized medicine I I very strongly support in in a way and the way
being that I think that poor people should absolutely have adequate health care
if they get injured,
if they get sick,
they shouldn't be fucked and saddled down with debt.
They're already poor.
And I think that it also should be something that society,
if we're going to take care of our citizens,
we're going to,
we're going to provide good roads,
we're going to provide schools.
How could we not provide healthcare?
It seems like a really important thing,
but then again,
if you're a doctor and you've fucking struggled through school and you've,
you know,
you've made it to the top of your profession,
you should be adequately compensated for your hard work and effort.
So I'm torn in a way and that I think that absolutely there should be some sort
of socialized medicine as some sort of socialized health care and it should be a
part of the services that a society provides.
I also,
I don't want to see doctors suffer and be disgruntled and pissed off because
they have $500,000 in fucking student loans.
And you know,
the government wants to pay them $50,000 a year to take care of people 12 hours
a day.
I think that's ridiculous too.
So I think if we do have socialized medicine,
I think doctors have to be adequately compensated.
If they're not,
you're not going to get the same effort that you're going to get from people
that are in a capitalist medical society where the best doctors cost more money
and they're better.
They're just better.
We have a lot of fucking,
we have people that fly from all over the world to come to the United States
because some of the doctors that we have are the best in the world in their
field.
And those guys,
they should just,
they deserve money.
They've made it to this position by being excellent.
So I'm torn in a way.
I mean,
I,
I don't think anybody should ever go without healthcare.
W if they get injured,
they should certainly be taken care of.
If they get sick,
they should get medicine.
But you know,
it comes to a distribution of money.
Yeah.
It's interesting isn't
it?
Because you,
you can,
you can't view it as a utopia because there is no single solution,
but certainly is that the health,
the NHS as we call it,
the national health services is sort of a global freak.
There's nothing else like it,
right.
It costs us a fortune.
I'm literally,
I'm going to a,
as a percentage of GDP,
I don't know the figure,
but it's fast.
Um,
and it is an amazing thing,
but once you scrutinize the costs and where the money actually gets spent,
of course,
naturally in any modern,
mature bureaucracy,
too much of the money gets spent.
Not Making people better,
not paying the doctors and not spending it on medical care.
It's in middle management.
It's in infrastructure,
it's in waste,
of course.
And that's like charity.
Yeah.
It's just,
that's the great frustration with it.
Really.
Um,
how the fuck did we get there from driving through really this podcast.
But no,
we don't have a real structure.
No.
And I think it's um,
yeah,
strange on my,
my wife's a doctor and I think,
uh,
I think that one of the frustrations of watching her generation of,
of,
of colleagues and graduates is that they graduated sort of just before the.com
boom.
So late nineties and their comeuppance there,
they're kind of grinning moment was that when the rest of us had finished
getting pissed and behaving badly at university for three or four years and
they'd had to work.
So every time we'd stack it in at five in the morning,
shit faced and they'd had to say,
I didn't go out last night,
I've got to get up and do something serious tomorrow morning.
They turned around and they all got jobs straight away.
Fair enough.
Cause they'd worked hard and they all learnt reasonably good money.
But then the.com thing happened and suddenly pretty much everyone who'd been a
loser and a drop out and done their work suddenly start earning more money than
them.
And they're all saying,
well hang on a minute.
I changed.
I've trained for eight years and I earned less than the person that's working on
some reception at Goldman Sachs.
So how does that work?
Um,
but I think if you like anything in life,
if you start to plot what happens strategically over time,
they don't do too badly because they are mostly insured and,
and sort of de-risked against the,
the,
the boom and bust cycles aren't they?
Doctors can earn money regardless of where you are on the economic cycle.
Um,
and they should have more.
Well,
you know,
what price do you put on someone that can,
that can save your life.
It's amazing,
isn't it?
You must have asked your quest that question.
You must have had some,
something happened to you where a doctor's really helps you out.
And if you did a sort of matrix style freeze frame of that moment and said,
right,
given my net worth,
what would I be willing to give to that person because of what they've just done
to me?
It's a lot of money,
isn't it?
Yeah.
I think we've all had moments.
We've just thought,
I'll give you everything.
I think you're so wonderful actually give you everything,
especially when it comes to life changing things like cancer or you know,
spinal injuries or something along those lines.
Yeah.
And then about 10 minutes later of course,
once it's all subsided we will calm down and think no,
I wouldn't give them anything.
I buy another horse.
Um,
so uh,
your green Porsche,
the famous Kermit,
whatever you call it,
the green fucker.
Shit,
it ain't shit or that you built this 1972,
it was on a 72 shell.
Yeah,
I love that car.
I seriously thought about building one of those.
Alex from shark works.
Kind of talk me out of it.
We talked about doing an older air cooled car and you know,
he was his,
his thought is once you have one of those gt three Rs is with a 3.9 liter,
502 horsepower engine and he's like,
you're just not going to be able to deal with that little car.
It's just not the same.
But I think there's something pure about those little tiny lightweight cars.
Yours was like,
what,
2100 pounds or something like that.
And English money,
it was just over a ton,
switched over a thousand kilograms.
So 2100 pounds,
which is extremely light for a car.
And then 300 and probably 340 horsepower on a proper Porsche,
340 horsepower.
So that's like a Ferrari.
The one of those five.
Um,
it was a mega think they're interesting,
aren't they?
Can we can get geeky now because you've got some car people that listen to this,
the lot the,
and people were very excited to have you on the difference.
The difference between the car you've got and the on the older cars is
definitely one of size and interaction.
It's stranger than motor vehicle.
You can add very small amounts of girth to,
to a car and that sort of becomes exponential on the road.
The feeling of size.
You only have to make a car 2030 mil wider and suddenly you feel that you're
taking it more and more of the road.
You have fewer options,
fewer lines you can take in a turn.
And so it becomes less wieldy.
Yeah.
And,
and you become conscious of that and I think you're driving adjusts accordingly.
So the smaller cars,
the older cars definitely have that about them.
Of course there are more tactile because they don't have assisted steering.
They don't have,
you know,
they have flow hinge paddles.
They have,
there's lots of other things that are interesting classic about them.
You can give them breaks but it's standing,
they don't have much breaks.
Um,
and they tend to,
what they tend to do is they tend to offer a lot more interaction of fun at
lower speeds.
That's,
that's what I,
what I would say.
I'd say in a,
in a nice 2.4 s from 73,
you can probably get your kicks and feel that you've had something from the car
by not driving it that hard.
Um,
and by just mooching around you,
you're probably busier whereas your car in econ need to get up.
And there's a personality about,
particularly the GT series Porsches from 99 onwards where they go,
do they go do the engines?
If you draw,
if you,
if you don't rev it beyond three,
you really feel that you've missed out.
Basically if you've taken the hot back to your room and you've made her a cup of
coffee and gone to sleep.
And I think you really,
whereas I think the older cars offer a little bit more,
the green car was complete folly.
I mean it was developed with a friend of mine,
Richard Tuttle,
and they make amazing rally cars.
I mean,
you know what's ago and one of their things that are off the scale,
well you didn't even have a key,
you had a switch.
Hey,
we just had a toggle switch.
We didn't see that was that we thought that was really cool until I found
someone sitting in it just,
just,
just the probably ready to steal it.
But I mean,
yeah.
Well as you found someone saying,
yeah,
what was I Bristol or somewhere and um,
I just politely asked him.
He wanted to get out of my car and he did and walked off.
Did you ask him what the fuck he was doing?
No,
he was,
he looked like had probably done far too many plus eight so I don't know what he
was going to do but drugs and he was kind of um,
it made me realize that the coolness of the lack of security probably wasn't the
cleverest thing we could have done.
But we ended up,
we ended up actually hiding and electronic cutout on it.
Some are a bit sneaky so that then that,
then it went,
he works cause you could just give it that one.
And then I just liked the simplicity of the toggle.
It was nice.
I also hate started buttons in cars don't you?
I think they're the most pathetic invention.
W M three that as a starter button and I like it cause I just get,
you don't have to do,
you don't have to use a key d.
A lot of them like a Ferrari.
You're getting it,
you turn the key on and then you have to hit a button on the steering wheel.
That seems too,
why would you do that?
I like the fact that I have my key in my pocket.
I grab a hold of the door number three.
Well I sit down in the car,
I pressed the button,
it starts.
I love that.
I do love that.
I think what was liberating about the,
the green car was it was a bit like,
um,
it was a bit like a food critic being told to cook a meal.
I'd spent at that stage probably 10 years criticizing everyone else's work.
I was the critic and the critic is quite low creature actually in,
in,
in the scheme of things,
you just go along and you saw that and that's very good.
I don't think that's very good.
I think that's not bad.
And that's based on your experience with the cars and you hope that people think
those are valid opinions,
but you've never actually done it yourself.
So I wanted to do it myself.
I wanted to make a car that I thought roughly approximate it to what I wanted in
a driving device,
in an aesthetic object.
And I really enjoyed the process.
It was really,
really enjoyable and I was amazed at how wrong we got it at times.
We just got it so profoundly wrong and it was so eyeopening the process to work
out where the money goes.
I mean it was just hopelessly inefficient.
And Richard and I are really good mates and we,
neither of us really got any clue with money at all.
And he'll admit that.
And we just,
the bills just racked up and up and up.
We've got this bloke to do the trimming inside the car.
I wanted not too much trim,
but whatever it was there,
I wanted to be of exceptional quality.
So I wanted to stitching to be by hand on the panels on the dash.
And I wanted an alkyne Tyler roof and I wanted the recaro seats trimmed.
And we've got this bloke in from Jaguar who does all the,
um,
the show cars.
So it does those beautiful interiors.
And when the bill came in,
I just said to Richard was clearly wrong.
There's like two astronauts on it.
Well,
why was he doing?
He's putting too many Zeros on the,
on the bill and we couldn't work it out.
Trimming cars like that just costs a fortune.
And I didn't know how expensive was.
So oddly enough that then alter my perspective.
So when I next got in a small volume sports car rather than going,
oh,
that's a bit shit that trim there,
what have they done that I immediately thought,
I now know why they've done that because actually for the money they could have
had spent on that trim,
they've actually probably given us a better differential.
They're probably given us better dampers.
There were probably five things about the car dynamically they could have spent
that money on that made the vehicle much better than if they'd gone for the
fancy panel on the dashboard.
Well that's why something like singer is such an interesting approach.
Like they've gone all high end.
If you don't know what singer is,
singer vehicles
in California,
they take a nine six four which was a 19 what an 89 to 92 93 something like
that.
Porsche and they,
they strip out everything.
They take all the body panels off.
They replace them with carbon fiber body panels that mimic the long hood models
between 70 and 73 is that what it was?
The long hood ones,
but they will from the very start,
they were long hood so you could save from 64 actually,
right?
Yeah.
And they um,
they put this incredible Cosworth engine in it.
They put this amazing,
beautiful interior,
everything,
carbon fiber,
hand stitched,
everything be spoke.
And the cost is staggering.
They start at like $300,000 us and they get up to well over half a million for a
nine,
six,
four.
And you know,
and I really dynamically,
the way it drives,
it's a nine,
six,
four with a souped up engine and a good suspension.
Both you and I agree that live,
we had half a minute spend on a car.
We'd have almond milk because they are just amazing.
I was with Mars last night.
Mass has got a hangover at the moment.
Um,
and uh,
so he's very Masterman sing it.
But yeah,
we've got,
you've got to be careful about the singer.
It's,
it's,
you can't say singing on 11.
I just did.
So I didn't say it for legal reasons.
Is it good?
It was a very careful legal position.
So it's a,
it's a reimagined nine 11 that happened to be made by a company called singer.
So is there an issue there that's just,
there has to be straightforward.
Yeah.
You Porsche don't like anyone playing with their IP too much,
so they just got to be quite careful with how do they feel about singer?
Um,
he says,
yeah,
they,
I think on an engineering level and account enthusiast level,
they love it.
But I think also the,
they view it as their thing now that is the most,
one of the most recognizable products on the planet and someone else's.
Okay.
Playing with it.
So in a big way.
Yeah.
I mean it's,
it looks like a 73 but it's a s 1989 and then
it's a stunning thing though,
I think of all the cars I've driven in the last three years,
that's,
that's one of the top few that I really,
I'd put my money into it.
I just think they're gorgeous.
Absolutely gorgeous.
It's a beautiful car,
that's for sure.
And they do drive brilliant new as well.
And I love the story behind it.
Rob British guy who's,
you know,
spent six months messing around with modeling clay to get the shapes on the
fenders.
Right.
And it was a lead singer in a band.
Yeah,
yeah.
When he's the cousin of Bruce Dickinson,
who's,
I'm the lead singer of iron maiden.
There's,
that's the know.
So there's,
there's,
there's there,
there's rock in the blood.
So what band was he in again?
What was Robin?
I don't know what ban Robert.
Well,
Robert Forgotten your band name.
Sorry.
He Wa he was in a pretty good,
you know,
well known band.
Um,
and I just loved the story and I both,
I think any product is naturally enhanced by the,
by the narrative behind it,
isn't it?
And the singer,
the singer story is lovely and they just wicked blokes,
but do that.
They're cooking on gas now.
So to start with it was,
crikey,
can we build three of these right now?
It's,
you know,
how do we build all the cars we've got orders for?
I mean they've,
they've really taken off what a weird world we live in where they can't fill
enough orders of half a million dollar cars.
It,
well the car,
he's bizarre isn't it?
And it has,
it's taken on a new form that has shocked even people like me.
Cause I,
I've always felt confident that people will spend money on cars,
big money on costs because we all bump into people that have resources.
And it seems that the motorcar is something that more often than not,
they like,
um,
and,
and yet I'm stuck at by the fact that,
you know,
Mclaren can build 395 p ones and they just sold out a couple of days after they
announced it.
And the one is how many million is 1,000,009 or some crazy shit probably.
Yeah,
probably is that means that a Laferrari is over too,
isn't it?
I mean
the one,
the one that actually is baffling is the portion on 18 because they built 918 of
those.
And I sat several times in interviews with Mr Hats,
who is the boss of vice arc in Porsche to the r and d development place.
And the man that makes those decisions and has to stand by them.
And I just sat goading him saying,
you'll never sell 918 of those,
you just won't.
And you know,
look at,
look at Mclaren and Ferrari.
You have taken a more sense,
we'll have to do,
I think it's 499 la Ferrari's and there's 395 p ones.
Those seem like realistic volumes,
but 918 of a vehicle,
that's what's that over here?
It's a,
it's a million quid.
More than a million dollars.
Yeah.
So it must be 1.4 million.
I would have thought.
Um,
they've just sold them all.
They've just announced they've sold them off.
So I've got,
I've basically got to wear a tee shirt that says I'm sorry I was wrong the next
time I see him.
Wow.
Um,
so,
but there,
there is this huge appetite for it.
And also there is,
um,
I suppose there's a parallel with the advertising photographer from the 80s
which was,
you almost couldn't say this off of you are too cheap.
Could you,
you know,
if you,
if someone approached you and said,
you know,
you're a great photographer,
how much for a day?
Shoot.
And he went as 5,000 pounds,
they'd get in there,
you're not expensive enough.
And you'd go,
Oh damn,
why didn't I say I was 50,000 pounds?
And it's the same in the car world.
I think if you,
you'd be trying to sell something at 200 grand now sterling,
so let's say three,
250 to $300,000 you're slightly a no man's land.
You're not bespoke enough to be really special,
but you're probably more expensive than the average are eight nine 11 by wants
to spend money on.
So you're a nomas.
And so you've got to sort of take yourself out there.
And if you take yourself out to that weird place where the billionaires look and
just say,
there it is.
It's a million,
2 million,
5 million.
I'm just making it up.
They just buy into it.
And of course if you can then make that stick at that top end,
you could bring the volumes down that makes you more exclusive and then they buy
into the exclusivity as well.
Um,
guess a mad world when you follow it.
And also the great thing about the three hyper cars that everyone's talking
about at the moment is that quite a few of blokes that have them,
of course,
all three,
you know,
so the number of people who've got a 18 and a Laferrari
and a and a p one as there's several of them.
That's insane.
I saw a big Bugatti Veyron in public,
and when I saw it all,
I can think the number one thing,
I thought there's $1 million,
there's a million plus dollars in,
in a,
you know,
whatever at 10 foot little segment.
But did you want it now it's an ugly car,
ugly.
I don't,
I,
that's not the kind of car I like.
It's a big,
heavy,
super powerful car.
It's like,
it's not an intriguing to me,
you know,
it seems like a wild rocket ship and it's kind of interesting,
but it's so over the top what I drive it for a day.
Yeah,
it'd be fun to drive,
but to own it.
No,
it just seems,
it seems ridiculous.
He had the failure on,
he said he's a really weird thing.
I wonder how,
I wonder how history will remember it.
It's,
it's,
it's sort of a piece of engineering for the sake of a piece of engineering.
That's what it is.
It's a demonstration of what the Volkswagen group could do at the time and for
that,
it's fascinating and it will be remembered for technologically for several
things.
I mean,
it's the first really fast cars.
He's a dual clutch gearbox.
That was,
that was the thing that hit me when I first drove it because before that you
either had those shit actuated manuals,
the sort of original paddle shifters,
the Flores f one and whatever Lamborghini called it,
shit tronic or something.
I don't know.
I mean they just Audi r eight up until recently,
right?
Yeah.
So you had,
you had these transmissions sort of limited the experience they got in the way
of it.
Whereas you've got in the veil on and you suddenly just had this little panel
and he just pulled it and you had instant gear shifts.
So and that's in conjunction with his four wheel drive meant that yes you had a
cane pathic of over a thousand horsepower,
but that doesn't really matter.
You can claim any numbers what you can actually put onto the road at any one
time that matters.
Net usable performance or power,
let's say.
So have you had a thousand horsepower in the mid eighties if you had a car that
did have that power,
you probably only have 30% of that available.
Anyone time.
By the time you had shit ties a shit transmission and everything else wasn't
working,
you wouldn't have the performance.
The,
what struck me with the Vayar almost even on a slightly damp road in an emulsion
where the factory is,
you could kind of use 80 90% of that performance and that created all of the
other problems,
which was that I'd never driven on the road that fast before.
It was just crazy.
You were so far out of sync with any other piece of traffic and the things quite
big as well.
It's quite big.
It's quite heavy and of course once you get up to those speeds you have to get
back from them quite quickly as well.
So I suppose that was more of a super bike mentality.
It did stop and the veteran was,
wasn't always has been just this ridiculous connection of numbers and they
continue into the ownership experience as well.
So you know,
because of the MAG wheels and the tires,
they will learn.
I think you can only change the rims and the tires two or three times.
Then you've got to replace the wheels as well.
So that's why it's,
that's 25 $30,000.
Why is that?
Just because they,
they won't,
they won't allow them to carry on just against,
they've got cracks in them cause their magnesium,
everything about the vehicle had to be engineered to a level that allowed
maintenance so that you could go into 250 and it whenever you wanted or
whatever.
It would do 246 miles an hour.
And that meant some of the top end stuff was really,
really extreme.
Particularly on wheels and tires and consumables.
It is the most expensive carve his type to run ever.
I mean the Laferrari,
the p one and the nine 18 are child's play compared to a very wrong,
and that's why very values are so suppressed.
I mean,
is it,
it's the value car out there now because you can't just buy one and stick it in
the garage and hope it's going to go up.
You'll stick it in the carriage and before you sell it again,
someone will want $50,000 to do something to it.
Right.
And that's what suppresses the values of them.
Yeah.
It seems like it's not a car that's going to be valuable in 10 20 years from
now,
whereas like a Ferrari f four 30 is going to be valuable in the future.
You know,
will it,
I mean I think a manual one might I think,
I think,
uh,
I think the manual at four 30 I shouldn't be saying this is probably the sneaky
one out there at the moment because it's hard to find them.
They are,
what's the last manual?
Berlinetta v Eight Ferrari.
So that's worthy of celebration because there was no manual for five,
eight.
Um,
I could see that being worth a few quid in the future.
I mean the favor on will be worth money,
but I just don't know.
I just don't know how you're going to maintain them.
Said the nine five nine is a similar car actually if it's era cause they're 40
values just sprung up straight away two or three years ago.
And another story of them in America,
what does the day the other night with vine,
yeah.
Yeah.
You had to and you had,
they let have them all sitting in a,
in a lot,
didn't they?
They couldn't actually distribute,
couldn't distribute them because they weren't crashed.
Tested.
So Bill Gates bought two and crashed one.
Did he?
Yes.
Brilliant story crashed one a million dollar classic Porsche nine five nine
crash tested it just so that they could get it to pass in America.
And that was that from the original batch back in whenever 19 no,
I don't know where he got it from,
but I remember it was a big story that he had bought two so he could crash one
and drive one.
What a wonderful story.
Yeah,
the knife was the VA one of its era because it has advanced technologies in it.
One of which was a,
you know,
you go buy a 78 well I guess it's a hundred plus thousand dollars now Nissan Gtr
and it would bury that Co.
Of course it would.
But that's progress,
isn't it?
And I think that people that buy into old cars aren't too worried about
comparing modern performance with all before.
That's a problem with something like a very Ron [inaudible].
Ron,
the big thing about it is the fastest car you can buy,
that's why it's $1 million.
It's an unbelievably obscene,
really fast.
But if you were on a real track like the Nurburgring with a VA Ron and a GTR,
the GTR would probably be,
yeah,
I think the VA Ron has never really been a track car.
The Va runs just to stick it in a straight line and go really fast in it car and
I've never driven anything like it's still for a straight line performance.
I think we did.
What was it at the time?
It was the quickest it had done on the public road.
We borrowed one in about 2006 and uh,
we had the car for a day.
That's the way it works.
You could borrow the car for a day and a Julius Kruta.
Hello Julius.
He was the guy that sort of manage the loan.
Great Guy.
He was in charge of,
his job title was brilliant.
It was sort of,
he was like an antiquarian bookseller.
He was in charge of heritage and stuff like that.
And um,
and he handed the car over and we shot it in a group test,
normal sort of magazine scenario.
And we did it for all to,
I think it was,
and we had an hour rate and some other stuff and we did some bits and bobs and
then the shoot finished when the light faded.
But we still had this car and everyone else going back to the hotel.
And I said,
well,
we've got this thing for a day.
I'm using it for a day,
you know,
when it gets dark through the night,
why would we stop using it?
Let's go and do something.
And we had a video camera with us.
We said,
well,
let's go,
you know,
we're near Germany,
we'll just hop over the border and we'll,
um,
we'll go fast on the autobahn.
I'd never been fast.
You need to have effectively a second key to make the Vero and going through it
super fast mode where the big wing comes out the back.
Yeah.
It's just,
it's a second effective is second mode.
It's a bit like the old corvette Zr one where you had this set.
I think it is a second key and that then lowers the car and puts it into super
fast mode.
Cause before that would you believe it is limited to 236 I think it's crazy.
You know,
speed limits are and then,
but if you want to do the final 12 miles an hour,
you have to have the,
we didn't have the special key.
Um,
but we went out on the Autobahn in a,
we have two cars.
We had exactly the same car as yours,
but stock standard.
So we have the Porsche press orange nine nine seven gt three Rs gen one 3.6 and
we had a very rum and photographer and another driver and he got to about
midnight and we waited for the a five nickels river,
which is a great piece of auto bonus.
It's like five lanes wide undulates a bit,
but there's a good long fast action is totally de restricted.
Um,
we're waiting for it to clear a bit and we just thought,
well,
we'll see how fast the car will go.
And just,
so we did a couple of kind of bearing in mind,
this is a road where a hundred is a cruise,
120 is you're moving a bit,
140.
There's a lot of people doing that and regularly people come past it in one 60,
one 70 even then that's,
that's the way of the world in Germany.
Um,
but anything over one 70,
you're quite anomalous,
you know,
there's not many of you doing that.
And we use the very one gets from 130,
280 very quickly.
And then from one 80,
from from one 80,
it feels like at the time it felt like no car.
I had driven before because,
uh,
an LP,
six 70,
um,
mercy Alago Lamborghini that that can get to 190,
quite quickly,
180,
but after that,
those next 20 miles an hour,
you watch the needle just creep and you watch the numbers come up,
a single digits,
just click,
click,
click.
The very one just goes bang.
So we did a couple of runs were it just hit 200 and I thought,
well that's quite interesting.
So let's see how fast we can go.
So we put the camera in it and this,
this did a lot of hits on Youtube.
I remember.
And we just went and see how fast it would go and there was still traffic out on
the road.
And we did,
we did 227 in amongst and amongst all these other cards.
And um,
and I just kept my foot pinned for a bit longer and just kept it going.
And the push that your car was behind us following as a structure,
sort of a,
yeah,
it was like a support car really to make sure everything's all right.
And had a camera on the front of it I think.
And,
and we had radios and I got so far ahead of it and he was doing,
I remember we stopped,
the support was really,
really hot and he stops the next services and I was really frazzled because I'd
not been that fast on the road before.
And everything looks different.
You know,
you do tunnel in a bit on the sides.
You have to be very,
very careful.
The cards I start to wonder a little bit,
you pick up cambers everything just behaves a bit differently and you have to
have your wits about you more than I thought.
I thought you'd just put your foot down and go.
And I'd done 200 many times before,
but the extra 27 miles an hour,
it was like entering a new zone.
And um,
it was amazing to talk to someone who'd been driving then one of the fastest
sports cars on the planet,
the Gt three Rs.
And he just said,
you,
you went out of sight.
We couldn't see.
You got so far ahead,
but it was like you were in a different type of vehicle altogether.
You just went,
you might as well have been in an aircraft.
It was mega and after that I suppose there were a lot of people at the time just
saying it's not a McLaren f one it's too heavy.
It's not fast run a track elite,
it's breaks.
But when you've done that speed in one in traffic and then felt the way it
stops,
the felt,
the way it responds.
You do have some respect for the car you do and you,
I think you create an emotional bond with it that you,
you can't really relinquish so,
so I am a,
I'm actually a very wrong defender because I felt what it can do and what it was
designed to do.
I think part of the problem with the veil and is that the,
the design brief for it was flawed.
You can't blame the vehicle for being flawed if,
if the reason it exists was a bit flawed that you see my logic here,
I think if they'd set out to make the best driving hypercar of all time,
they probably would have done it.
But what they actually set out to do was to do 250 miles an hour safely and
reliably.
That in itself is bonkers.
I mean,
when you talk to the engineers about the engine,
it's rated at what,
over a thousand horsepower.
But apparently it can put out so much more.
It can,
you know,
it could have 1300 horsepower,
but it needed to without even thinking about it,
1300 if it needed to,
it needed to.
So it's,
yeah,
it's,
it's a strange thing,
but here's the question,
is it a more pleasurable drive then your green Porsche that has 340 horsepower?
No,
that's the,
that's the great debate amongst all of us car people,
isn't it?
And like I vacillate hugely between the two and I'm completely spoiled.
So I'm the last person to ask because what I'll tend to do is go through phases.
I think all men go through phases.
You go through car phase is high five phases,
watch phases where you're a little fad is the thing that you're into and
sometimes things are really important.
Then they drop away and you can spot it by the dates of the magazines you've got
in your house.
Aren't you all haven't bought high fi magazine for a bit.
Um,
and I think I'm like that with cars.
I kind of need all the fixes.
So if you gave me,
if I woke up tomorrow morning,
I'll probably tell you I'm in a bit of a delicate phase,
so I'd quite like to have an at least I'd like 118 horsepower basic earlier
lease on original p Zeros to it's fucking lethal in the wet.
Um,
and I liked the challenge and I like the fact that it's not that fast.
You've got to carry momentum.
And I,
I take joy in the long travel suspension,
I'd,
I'd
celebrate everything that's great about Lotus and the purity of it.
But then after a month I'd probably quite light something just to swap me fast
and straighten this.
I'd probably want a Gtr with a thousand horsepower and I'll probably drive that
for a month.
And I love it and I wouldn't miss the loads of the tool and I'd love the
performance and I constantly am myself in trouble with the law.
But then after that month,
I probably think God would you like a nine 11 and and I this is the problem with
it.
I don't think there's an answer.
I think broadly speaking,
the cheaper for the lighter purist route is where I sit broadly speaking.
But I'm not a purist.
I cannot tell you that I can adhere to one single philosophy of,
of the type of fast car that I want.
I think it's a broad church and I want it all.
I agree.
I like a light car and,
and I,
I like a,
a really good handling car,
but occasionally like an American muscle car.
I used to have a Shelby gt 500 and it was a fun car.
I didn't really enjoy driving.
Was that one,
2011 so 550 horsepower one not the big one.
That's 668 the the recent one,
but it was fun.
I mean,
it was so stupid.
You don't need anything more than 550 horsepower.
Anytime I want it to,
the tires would break lose.
Anytime I'm turning a corner,
all I'd have to do just give it a little extra juice and why that'd be sideways
around the corner.
It was fun.
It was stupid live Rear Axle,
completely archaic Caveman car,
but it would make me smile all the time.
Just the sound of the rumble,
the VA and the wine of the supercharger.
Just combine with all that together.
It was fun,
stupid fun,
but they really do make that shrieking noise.
It's so much more retarded than the Porsche cause the Porsche,
everything feels balanced out.
Even the shark works 502 horsepower version of it.
It seems balanced out.
Like you have to rev it up to get the real power or there's a lot of,
you know,
you've got (800) 800-0800 Rpms till you hit the red line is a lot going on
there.
Where's would that Shelby first gear,
stomp the gas.
You're going completely sideways.
The car just,
it would just go,
it just,
it can't keep up narrow tires.
It doesn't have the right amount of traction.
Ridiculous engineering.
It's not a car that's designed,
they took a regular Mustang and they just said,
let's just get crazy with this regular Mustang.
And it's stupid.
But there's something fun in that stupidity that would always make me smile when
I drove it.
Well,
I think,
but it comes down to the broad church,
doesn't it?
The thing I've just explained,
I've,
I,
if I had,
if you had to keep that as your only car for three years,
I get bored.
It would worth in the joke would wear thin.
He'd want something different.
So actually what we're saying is to all you men out there,
um,
and women that are into the subject,
this is your excuse.
You've got to have lots of cars.
You can't,
you can't have,
you know,
I always try and keep things a bit balanced and I,
I tend to get it wrong,
but I've got something that's Italian and stupid and,
and to make me look like I've got a tiny Willie.
Um,
and I've got some German stuff which works and I really appreciate the
engineering and I've got some old French tat that I really enjoy because it just
makes me feel alive and pleasurable and it's,
and it's light and clever and gallic.
Um,
and I've,
you know,
I've got something that goes off road and I think you need all of that.
And it's just all of these things are excuses to waste money,
right?
That's what it's all about.
And once you've done that,
you can then cover all the bases off and of course you will always be in the
wrong car for the job.
That's,
that's the whole point of it all being a current thesis is about
shouldering the pain and the burden because you'd never in the right thing.
So if I,
if I wake up and I go,
I'm going to go out in my five,
12 Ferrari,
great.
And I get the thing started up,
you know,
and I can't guarantee it's going to start,
but if it does start and we'd go out in it,
that's the day that my wife will phone and say,
can you go and collect two of the children from school?
And I'll go,
I can't.
And she'll go,
why?
That's just so selfish.
So the car basically caused the social issue at home.
So they blame the car.
You know,
if I'd been in the m five then I could have done it,
but I wouldn't,
I didn't do it cause the law of Murphy means I didn't have it.
And then the time that I'm out in the two CV with 12 horse power is the time
that I'll come up against some young gun in an evo and I'll want to learn him.
And I wish I was in a fast car,
but I'm in the bloody TCV so I can't do anything about it again.
Like you're always in the wrong tool for the job.
I think when you go to,
you just got back from Jay Leno's garage when you go to jail and it was gross.
Do you feel like this guy's got it.
Nailed it.
This is how you do it.
You just have everything that's ever been built and you put it in a fucking
warehouse.
Yeah,
I was.
I asked him about that because I said,
what a nice man he is.
I said,
okay,
look,
I've got,
I don't know,
I've got double figures,
carbs,
but they are worth nothing.
My,
you know,
I've got one or two cards that might have some value,
but most of them are worth thousands,
2000 pounds.
They'd rubbish and they never work.
They never start on the key.
I mean the whole point of having cars is that they work.
You don't want to have to,
you know,
if you get a red day off,
you want to drive the thing.
I don't want to,
I'm not a natural span.
I don't want to be playing with the thing.
I want to drive it.
So I said to him,
how many cars have you got?
Any went roughly 132 so he's got an idea and I said,
so how do you keep them?
So they turned on.
The key to is where we just do so when you walk in there,
they were just batteries everywhere.
Battery chargers everywhere and it does turn on a key.
He,
he,
he manages to do it so that he can use them.
And it's,
I've staff,
of course he does.
I mean it's,
it's a,
it's an opera,
it's a bloody industry.
It's not even a business.
It's incredible to view.
But I love the fact that they are there to start until work,
every single one is there to work.
So we were looking at a GM cyclone,
which for a Brit is a really fascinating vehicle.
That was I think in 91 it was the fastest vehicle GM made and it is a truck and
I'm such a cool thing and I'm,
I,
I food or she chose that moment to say to him,
so you know,
when did you last try this?
And
he went this morning and just put his hand,
he said,
put your hand on it.
Is still hot.
Damn.
Why didn't I choose something else to try and expose you?
Um,
uh
yes.
Steam engine,
car.
God,
he's got some amazing stuff.
I mean there's a believe that America,
if they,
they knew Jay Leno just solely based on his love of cars.
If he had gotten involved in a car show a long time ago instead of tonight show,
they would have a much more positive opinion of him.
How is he genuinely viewed?
I mean what cause he was,
he was,
he was the what was the show called?
The tonight show?
Yeah,
cause we just thought it was amazing.
We just don't know about that one.
Depends on the circles that you travel in.
A lot of people,
they lost a lot of affection for him because he was hosted the tonight show and
then Conan O'brien briefly became hosted the tonight show.
But the ratings dropped and it was partially because he had his own show at
10:00 PM and people watch that and they weren't watching the 11 o'clock version
with Conan O'brien.
And then he reclaimed the tonight show and that a bunch of people got angry at
him,
including a bunch of Hollywood people.
They thought that he's stolen from Conan O'brien.
I thought the whole thing was pretty fucking ridiculous,
but
he's,
he wasn't
the most real guy when it came to talking with people about some stupid fucking
movie that he really didn't care about or some album release that he's never
going to listen to the songs.
He just,
he didn't give a shit.
So he was just kind of like this gracious,
very friendly,
nice host who really didn't have any passion for what he was talking about.
But when you see him talk about cars,
he lights up.
He loves it.
He's wearing a Jean shirt,
you know,
and Jean Pants,
he just wears what he would normally wear.
He has Jay Leno's garage and he talks about these cars and you could see his
real knowledge and real passion and he,
he,
it's exciting.
It's fun.
I love watching his youtube show,
Django Leno's garage.
But I've always said to myself,
like,
if this guy just did that from the beginning,
people would have a totally different opinion of him.
He would be loved across the board,
especially by men who love cars and said,
people have this sort of like,
we'll lukewarm opinion of him.
He's,
he's in his,
no one gets excited about Jay Leno in America.
I a bit,
it's a bit like,
like
me telling you that story about top doing Argentina because I didn't know any of
that.
I didn't know that that was,
he was,
that was the perception of him in that space.
But I want a great bloke.
I mean,
he's probably the most convincing Carinthia just have ever met.
And I only met him three hours ago.
I mean,
he is,
he's so completely into the subjects.
He loves them.
He just took three hours to walk me around all of the rooms in his,
you can't call it a garage.
I mean it's a small town and uh,
and,
and he just,
the way he talks about the vehicles is that he celebrates the engineering within
them.
He's an engineering freak and he has a sort of fetish about weird engineering.
So he's,
he'll walk past something that has a value of $1 million and walk up to a
motorcycle that's probably worth $1,000 because it's got a radial engine housed
within the front wheel spokes.
And that when you bought it,
you were told rather than to stop,
to just do little sort of circles on it to stop it falling over because the
centrifugal force meant it meant it was easier in terms of oil distribution or
something.
I don't know.
And He loves the quirkiness.
He just loves quirky engineering and it's really compelling to listen to.
So yeah,
I mean I,
I think he's fantastic and I think the way that he talks about cars and the
stories behind them and the,
yeah,
the narrative behind all of it is fascinating.
And He loves the story.
He's a complete sucker for it.
He admitted,
he just said like,
I keep buying stuff because of the story binder.
I didn't need another one of those.
But then I spoke to the guy and he told me what they like,
Oh shit,
I better buy it now.
Um,
and I love that he's,
he's,
I love people who,
who are almost transfixed by their passion and you feel like there's just a sort
of,
there's an invisible rope just dragging them through a process and they don't
really have any control over it.
It's just happening.
And then they're along for the ride and they love it.
And I think that's exactly him.
Um,
yeah.
Well how interesting that that's the perception I suppose as a,
as a,
as a Brit who doesn't know anything about the talk show,
all I can say is that your,
your media business is the most advanced in the world.
If he was that bad at his job,
they wouldn't have kept him for that long.
And he was clearly doing something right.
Isn't that it was that bad.
He appealed in a strong way to middle America.
Middle America is thought to be the dumbest section of this country and they're
just,
you know what I mean?
I don't,
I think that's changing and a lot of ways because of the Internet,
the Internet is essentially making the entire country one big neighborhood and
that everyone has access to the same amount of information now where it didn't
use to be like that in the middle of the country you're dealing with the Bible
belt,
you dealing with a lot of people that are very religious and very close minded
and they want things very homogenized and pasteurized and that's what Jay Leno
tonight show come on and it would tell like he says hello by the way,
I've got some great guys.
He said to that guy and he's a sweetheart,
I really liked the guy but his,
his version of the show was the most successful version.
And what he did,
he figured out how to crack that code.
He figured out how to be the guy that is many people as possible with like,
and for whatever reason,
Hollywood didn't like him and they tried to move him out a couple of times and
he,
when,
when they finally got them away from the job,
he was number one.
He was number one and,
and late night TV.
It's very strange.
The whole thing is very strange.
It's just he never got the respect doing that.
But I still still to this day think that if he had a show and it was just about
cars,
he would be like one of the most loved men in America,
especially by men who love cars.
I think.
Yeah.
Well I think it's,
watch this space,
isn't it really?
I mean,
I think,
you know,
he's,
he's primed for it.
The Jay Leno's
garage brand is fantastic as youtube following,
it's got 1.2 million subs I think.
Ah,
the output loads of content very generously and he's making no money out of it.
It's all,
it's costing your money clearly.
Um,
yeah,
he,
he could be sort of the latent force in,
in car television over the next few years if he,
if he decides to.
It's kind of up to him I think.
Yeah.
He's like the American version of top gear and a lot of ways he just hasn't
gotten into it.
But all these other shows,
it's amazing that America has this incredible fondness for automobiles,
but very few really good automobile TV shows to hit strange isn't it?
But that seems to be the case globally.
There's top gear and is the UK known for his love of automobiles?
We have a,
yeah,
we have a strong relationship with the motorcar.
It's not as strong as yours.
Isn't that strange though?
Wait,
is I think that car television is,
is naturally a difficult format for broadcasters to get their heads around.
Instinctively.
People that run media companies tend not to be into cars.
Is,
is,
is one thing I'd say.
They are probably more of an intellectual bent.
Um,
and therefore don't quite understand the wasteful need to go and thrash cars
around and therefore it's not high on their list of priorities.
And because of that,
it becomes difficult to commission.
It's not cheap to make television around cars.
Um,
and for years the audience is just weren't there.
Most nations and broadcasters have attempted to do some car television but it's
not really worked cause it all started out as being sort of review car reviews
or product reviews,
wasn't it?
Um,
and then you fell into the,
that sort of really gray area of,
of,
of having,
you know,
commercial channels.
Cause all of your channels are commercials.
Most of yours are.
The BBC in the UK is that weird anomaly where it's effectively state funded.
We pay a license fee to it.
There's no advertising around it.
But of course that's the perfect template for a review program because you can
say anything is bad and it doesn't matter.
You won't lose,
you know,
you say the Ford focus is shit you fought,
can't turn around and go,
well we're not advertising anymore.
It doesn't matter.
Um,
so the review format was always a bit of a problem I think on,
on,
on an independent commercial channel because people find it very difficult to,
to watch someone say,
Oh,
the Subaru legacys brilliant,
well let's cut to a commercial break and it's a Subaru legacy and the
commercial,
I think most consumers struggle with that.
Um,
and so top gear was the first one to,
to turn it into an entertainment format and they were just brilliant.
I mean,
Jeremy and Andy Wilman just sat down and came up with what now and I've very
simple solutions,
but at the time no one had thought of them.
So they clearly were clever and sophisticated.
They just said it needs to be much more than just reviewing cars.
Cause frankly,
driving around in a small hatchback is pretty fucking dull.
Um,
it needs to engage the whole family,
so it needs to be entertaining.
Um,
and we need to do stuff with cars.
You know,
you see it.
If we think of cars too boring on its own,
let's do something with it.
Let's throw it off a building and blow it up.
Let's do something with it.
That makes it interesting.
Um,
and because of that,
it just created a momentum very,
very quickly actually that that meant that I think people were scared to compete
with it.
So you went from having a few players to having this one big plan.
I think everyone else went,
sat back and went,
I don't want to even attempt to enter that space cause we're going to look so
second or third best compared to top gear that it won't happen.
And that's when the sort of Internet shows that we will been involved in sprung
up over the last three or four years because no television company would,
would commission anything because they didn't want to be a second best to top
gear.
And then youtube came along with a bit of money and said,
well cars are cool people like car videos according to our stats on the,
on Youtube.
So why don't you make some content?
And that's where we sort of ended up really.
But it's still,
there is still a complete lack of motoring content that I'm into.
And I suspect you're into,
you know,
it's,
everyone has to do something clever with the car.
It's not enough just to say let's just have some really nice cars and do some
nice things with them.
And maybe that is too simplistic.
Maybe that does only target too small an audience,
but you know,
you have to basically modify it or you have to do,
you know,
yeah.
The car has to sort of be debased and defiled within the process,
which really pisses me off.
And I,
you know,
I've been asked to do a few things and I,
I don't want to modify a GTR,
don't want to cut the roof off a Rolls Royce.
It just doesn't interest me at all.
I want,
I'm into cars,
I'm not into sucking them.
That's what is exciting.
I mean that's what's attractive to some people.
And I think,
I think modification process,
I think that's just one part of it.
I think if you're a TV executive,
you immediately sit down and go right cars,
what can we do with cars to make them look interesting to people?
And what they miss is,
is the fact that inherently at the moment cars are so cool,
like a Laferrari.
Just the story behind the Laferrari,
the numbers,
the engineering and then that just the sheer visceral thrill of driving it and
the way it'll smack you up a road.
That's enough for me.
That's you know.
Whereas 15 years ago you was,
you know,
you were dealing in far less exciting cars.
Now the car is the star.
You almost don't need to do stuff with it.
I mean you,
you can watch top gear now is the barometer for how exciting and cars they've
there are so nailed down with the way they treat stuff that you can spot when a
car is really interesting because they just take it to the track and do the
track test and it,
one of them gets in it and it does pretty much what I do,
don't they?
They just get in it,
do some talking,
slide it around and then that's it.
But the moment they have to deal with something that's a bit less interesting,
they have to have a treatment.
Don't even know does that,
so if you dropped down a bit and m three we probably need to go and race a hang
glider with it.
And if it gets really bad like a Toyota I go,
or some little shit box has go and play football with 22 of them because there's
so uninteresting.
That's what we have to do.
And that is almost a metaphor for the way the car is treated in,
in mass media.
I think everyone's looking for an edge or a treatment and maybe there is an
audience just for Akasha.
He
says massively laded question.
But,
but,
but so no,
I think,
I think you do need to do something with cars.
You need to go on an adventure.
You probably need to explain the context because all of it is fascinating.
Um,
but you don't need to,
you just don't need all this peripheral stuff and you don't need to try and be
too clever with it and jokey with it.
And it was that modification scene.
I love modifying cars.
You know,
your car's modified.
I think that's brilliant.
But the idea of,
of having to sort of have a,
a really convoluted idea around the car to make it work as television is a bit
insulting to the motorcar.
Do you enjoy luxury cars as well?
Do you enjoy like Mercedes s class or an Audi a eight or anything?
Like anything?
I like any car.
I'm,
I have a medical condition.
As I said at the beginning.
I am,
I love anything.
I'll find joy in the hire car.
I'll find joy in a lawn tractor if it's got wheels,
I want to enjoy it.
Of course I'd have luxury cars and I,
I'd quite like the fact that I've,
I'm trying to do a deal with a luxury brand and known to run one for a bit.
Cause I,
I love wafting around and comfort.
I think everything,
cars to come back to the Gehrig portfolio situation.
You know,
car needs to serve a purpose.
If I want to get to the airport at four in the morning,
I don't really want to go in your IRS.
It's the wrong car.
It's this too fast.
I can't hear the radio in the morning and I want to hear the radio and I want to
have a coffee and yeah,
you've got a cup holder,
well done,
but your ride is so firmly will spit the coffee everywhere.
So what I like is probably an s class and I got a really nice three 50 diesel
less class.
That would be lovely.
And do you know what horror of horrors may be a lot going to drive it for me and
I can just sit in the back,
can write the story.
Um,
so now I love them and I,
I suppose I like,
I quite liked the absurdity and inverse snobbery of old luxury cars.
There's something very appealing about faded glory.
So sort of mid eighties rolls Royces,
bit of Rusp bubbling through them.
Um,
you know,
I think they're just hugely cool and I'd quite like to knock a bite and one of
those,
but we haven't got always testing cars.
Um,
I would quite like one at the moment.
I have to say,
what would I like?
I quite like a Bentley Mulsanne turbo or something really shit that just leaks
oil and has hydraulics that break the whole time.
You just look like you just look like a,
you just look like a bit of a drug dealer.
And I quite liked,
I think it look quite cool as a lovely story.
You know,
you've got a bit of time and the lovely story about the coolest Rolls Royce of,
well there was um,
there was uh,
a family that owned a company called catering.
Um,
and they were great and I'm probably getting it myself and legal trouble.
No,
I'm not.
Um,
and they had the sons that ran the company had a,
a Rolls Royce they'd bought from an auction,
fuck,
fuck all money.
It was like four grand and it was um,
it was beige or sort of Jewish racing gold as they call it in the motor trade in
the UK.
It was like horrible bronzy beigey color.
And rather than take taxis everywhere and they're out in London,
they bought this Shit Rolls Royce and they met a friendly cab driver that had
driven them around a few times.
And they said,
right,
I think it's called Sultan Sultan.
You get to keep Rolls,
Royce is yours.
You just keep it in the gallery.
You can use it whenever you want.
The deal is whenever we want you,
you pick us up in the Rolls Royce and you take us to places and we're out in
town or whatever.
And that's the way it works.
This thing had sort of RUSP bubbles all down the side and it had an APP,
a massive Alpine high fire had been fitted through some contra deal I think
without points.
So they've got their own fitness to massive amount of high Phi in it.
And all it had was ACDC.
This,
I remember you were,
you were not allowed to listen to anything else.
And it had this between the back seats where you,
the two people would sit in the back.
There was a,
a really crappy old cool box.
And in the cool box was just Stella Artois,
which in England is known as wife Beater,
which is just quite an ugly beer really.
There's a sort of,
there's a luxury about stellar Artois over here cause it's,
cause it's kind of a French brand,
but actually in England is just known as wifebeater.
It's the lowest common denominator.
People get a bit fighty on it.
So you used to sit in this thing,
salt and would drive you summer.
We used to go to the rugby,
it's working,
it we just quite dignified and all the Range Rover's park up and people have
their hampers before they go on to watch the game.
And Salt would basically muscle his way into the car park with no at all.
We'd be in the back,
stellar Artois ACDC coming out of the back of it.
Russ bubbles all down the side of it.
And to this day that is the coolest Rolls Royce I'll ever go in.
Just a wicked machine.
Um,
and I,
I,
yeah,
I love that.
I like the faded glory of the slightly shit over the top luxury car.
Please tell me you agree.
I agree.
Now this is a,
there's a majesty about them and I,
and I think particularly the ones that cost way too much money in the period.
We're all a sucker for value.
We're all suckers for value.
Me,
we love saying to people that was a hundred grand and it was new.
I think people love beginning sentences with that to people that don't really
know.
I've got this job.
So that was 150 grand and you knew I gave three for it.
[inaudible] the clever responses.
That's cause it's fucking worth three.
Look at it.
It's a disgrace.
There's a loud,
yeah.
Ferris for old American luxury Cadillacs,
like old Cadillacs,
like 19 seventy's large ones.
I was watching this show a one of those west coast customs shows where they take
a,
an old car and they refurbish it for,
they did it for kid rock.
Uh,
the,
the rapper and musician,
whatever you wanna call him.
And,
uh,
he did like a 72 73 Cadillac giant long hood Cadillac and turned it into
essentially like a personal limousine with a slide up door and a ventilation
system that sucks out the smoke from his cigars and Oh,
it was amazing,
amazing,
beautiful,
beautiful car and just floats like a boat.
Like those things just flow like a boat on the highway.
Action suspension.
Yeah.
You could get me onto a Soviet where I could become a real bore.
Actually,
the art of comfort be completely lost in motorcars,
completely lost everything,
has to be firmly sprung,
have massive wheels on it for the marketing department,
it's all complete shit.
It's a totally unnecessary.
More often than not,
you want to be comfortable in a car.
So why not take some spring rate out of it?
Have a big squashy tie on it.
It's lovely.
You'll float along.
You get into a seventies Cadillac for a long journey on a straight road that's
got some bumps in it.
It's a much nicer car than most modern cars.
You get into an s class.
They're pretty because they've got coverage suspension,
but a seven series BMW and Audi A.
He'd been an RDA recently.
God Almighty,
I like there's concrete for suspension.
Totally unnecessary.
Your car,
your car needs to be from,
it's supposed to go faster on the Nurburgring.
That's,
that's what it's designed to do,
but luxury cars are not actually that luxurious.
It's quite weird because would ride is fundamental to luxury.
They spend all this time making sure there's no wind noise.
They make the power train silent and then you get in them and you're not this or
that.
You can't see me.
I'm shaking now,
but you're like shaking around and say,
well where's the suspension guys?
Yeah.
Do you,
what?
What is your favorite luxury car like?
What do you think does the best job of like providing that very comforting,
smooth.
What?
Road bump.
Absorbing ride.
I don't think there is a,
I suppose a new s class Mercedes on the smallest world and tires.
It's getting close,
but I don't think it's as good as it should be or could be real cause of the,
because of the way they have to have the large wheels.
And also a lot of it is legislation.
So they need like,
you know,
lane changing ability 150 miles an hour.
If you're going to have a lane change at one 50 to pass your euro whenever
legislation,
then you can't have the thing running like a 20 kilograms spring because you
will just rotate.
So I understand that it's not quite as simple as I'm as I'm portraying it,
but I think they've gone too far.
Uh,
if you,
if you drive a rolls phantom,
which is conventionally probably the best luxury car in the world over a really
bumpy road,
you're still aware of the fact that you,
and you're on a really bumpy road.
But if I gave you a Citroen ds from 1959 or 1960 that was set up properly and
drove over the same road,
you would be more comfortable in the citron.
Wow.
So,
so we've,
we've gone backwards in terms of comfort.
What a fantastically boring subject.
An s class recently when I was in Washington DC and I loved it.
I think it's good.
The new one or the old one,
new one,
brand new one,
and I was thinking,
I've never thought about owning an asset class,
but I rented this for a weekend.
Me and a friend of mine did some gigs down there and we were driving around his
thing.
I'm like,
this is something I can get used to.
It's so comforting.
It's like floaty,
like you chill out,
you get out of it,
you feel relaxed.
It's a very important distinction.
I think that you do find a level of just Karma and you are more relaxed.
I think you're a better road user.
I find myself just being kinder and I tend to be,
I try to be kind on the road or you know,
but you're in an s class,
you've nothing to prove your plutocratic.
You probably own the business,
you know,
you,
you sit in there and you view the world as a series of poorer people than you,
and you're quite comfortable with your position and you always drop into
character,
don't you,
when you're in these cars,
even if they're not yours.
I find myself doing that.
And,
and because of that you say,
of course you can pull out in front of the,
in front of me at the junction or you,
I don't care if you want to pull out in front of me there or,
or duck and you just go ahead and do it.
Cause I'm in an Escalade and the world's good around me and I've done a 1.6
Honda civic then you know,
fuck you,
I'll fight you.
I'm not you cause your massive.
Um,
but I uh,
no,
I think,
I think the s class is a,
is a work of art and it's remarkable that generation on generation,
it remains the market leader.
It's almost in a market of its own.
You know,
if you want a car in that space,
you'd tend not to buy anything else.
Even that pretty fantastic.
It's pretty fantastic.
I mean I've driven the,
I used to have an older BMW seven series and I really liked it a lot.
It was very comfortable.
What year was that to see the final one?
2007 yes.
It was a bangle one.
Yeah,
it was very nice.
It's very comfortable.
Nice understated.
You know,
I liked it because it was,
it didn't attract a lot of attention but as a very comfortable car had some
weird massage thing where like lift your butt up and down some sort of a weird
way and that it was designed to never let your body sit in one position.
So you never got numb legs I guess.
What engine did it have?
Five liter I do not remember was at seven 45 or seven 50 wheelbase.
Uh,
I don't remember.
That's it.
I love the luxury concept,
the luxury cars and re matter what engines and as long as it goes,
what are you,
that's a weird thing about the,
the Benz is this AMG thing where they have the AMG s class,
the s eight,
the 63 and then the 65 which is a,
which is kind of weird.
It's like,
you know,
now you have this twin Turbo v eight monster fucking rocket engine inside this
giant luxury car that he's supposed to be just sorta chillaxing it.
Yeah,
it's a way,
but I went all the way to Frankfurt and back from the UK.
It's quite a long drive in uh,
in one of those,
in an s 63,
it's a magnificent vehicle.
Well that's 63 is actually one 10th of a second faster zero to 60 then the 65
yeah,
the 65 fits perfectly into the category I was describing earlier,
which is make something stupid and then just name your price.
That's why they do that,
because the kind of the type of customer that walks into a,
showed them to buy a 65 doesn't want the 63 because it's not the most expensive
and they just walk in and say,
I want the most expensive one and [inaudible] job to provide,
to provide the hyperbolic statement and that has to be the twin Turbo v 12 which
is inferior to the 63 in every way.
Of course,
it is hard,
right?
It's the same with the g 65 you know,
the g 65 is largely unusable,
but,
but if you're,
you know,
if you're Russian Geezer with a lot of money and you're living in London,
you don't want to turn up to your mates and go,
I didn't get the most expensive one.
Well that g 65 that g wagon is such a shit box.
It's just a weird fucking bread truck.
Like a mailbox truck.
I like,
I like the normal one that these are one is great.
The diesel one is a proper car that you can use.
And they go,
they'll go off road property,
they've got three deaths you can lock,
you know,
there's no lines,
a proper car.
So it was like to the level of a Land Rover defender,
which is sort of shape I,
we'll go places to defend the,
couldn't hope to go cause yeah,
cause it's got three lockable diffs so if you put the right tires on a g wagon,
they're really proper.
Whereas the Land Rover,
it doesn't have that.
Um,
uh,
but the moment you start sticking,
you know,
AMG engines in them,
I mean the 60 is ridiculous,
but it deserves celebration for that.
Um,
just the,
the trash and controlled triggers so early on and as the ESP,
so you go and you could turn it into a corner of what you think is moderate
speed.
All the lights flash up and yes,
bonkers.
We had a good day out and one of those in Germany,
actually,
I wonder what car gets used.
One car that has massive off road capabilities gets used the least off road.
It might be the Lexus,
that big Lexus,
which is the,
the very comfortable version of the lane.
The of the,
the toilet.
These are what we call the Amazon.
The v eight.
Yeah.
It could be that 70,
I think they're amazing off road.
Oh yeah.
And,
and of course the,
the saying goes in Africa that you,
um,
you use a land rover to go into the desert and you use a land cruiser to come
out that does it because,
because you know,
you'll never see a Landrover products in,
in central Africa because they just don't sort of last,
well that was the thing with the Taliban that all of,
uh,
what's Osama bin Laden's people,
they all drove around and Toyota land cruisers and they were like,
this is like the ultimate endorsement of the land cruise.
These people that are involved in the war,
how does Toyotas Press Department deal with that?
How do you spin something positive from that when they all had snorkels on them
and the whole deal via [inaudible] it doesn't really work,
does it?
No,
no,
they're,
they're remarkable things.
But then all,
all motorcars really,
um,
beyond the most basic utilitarian hatchbacks.
And you know,
city cars tend to have a series of abilities or um,
yeah,
I suppose engineering solutions that are so far and above what the end user will
actually need.
And you find that in all areas,
you know,
and,
and I trade in that personally and I,
that's probably what owns in my living.
If I was to,
to sort of drill down into what it is that might be it because you give me a new
m three and I would go on a track for the video and we'll rinse the tires and
drive it sideways at 90 miles an hour and do all this other stuff.
But you know,
if anyone buys the car,
but the,
how many people actually do that with?
It's so few,
but they like to know it can do it.
Right.
Um,
and I think that's the point you're making with the off road thing.
You know,
why,
why do people buy the Super Duper Range Rover that's $180,000 and see pictures
of it in the desert,
but they're never going to do it.
But no,
they love knowing it can and then like getting into it with their mates and they
can point at the button that shows the desert logo and then the Cactus logo.
What was the cat?
I love the Cactus logo.
So I've got an old,
I've got a the last range over the three to two with the Va supercharged in it.
I just love it.
It's just the nicest thing.
I would never go off road at night cause I want to scratch it.
And um,
but it's got a button,
it's got a cactus on it.
It's like my kids,
I love the way kids feel that one of my kids just said.
So is that just in case she drive into a cactus?
I was like,
I'm going to answer,
but probably yes.
I didn't know what it does.
Um,
so yeah,
the,
the abilities of all of these vehicles so far outstrip what most people do.
Um,
and pontificate about the future because it's kind of a silly situation where
worried the horsepower wars,
like the American cars especially,
there's a challenger Hellcat that has 707 horsepower.
I drove it recently when I was in Denver.
Amazing,
amazing car.
Sounds fantastic.
It's very comfortable for an American car and it's sixty four thousand sixty
five thousand dollars.
I just sold credible bargain.
Jay Leno,
she's got one and it was parked there and I,
yeah,
I don't want to talk about it already because I have not driven one in
everyone's driven when I'm the only person on the planet is not driven to eat
fucking hell cats.
So I was going to fun.
It's fun car.
The,
the horsepower race
will probably continue for a bit.
Um,
I think there's a,
I think the engineers are a little bit diemel pappy because they might now
finally be viewing the end of the internal combustion engine.
BMW made an announcement or someone from BMW last week I think said that,
um,
they can see another 10 years of internal combustion engines and officer that we
might be straight into electric or at the very least you'll,
you'll ice,
um,
might just be a range extender that supports a platform that's broadly speaking
electric.
So if we've got 10 years left,
you know less,
let's go for it.
Um,
almost bucket list style.
And I think that we,
I think we're beginning to see elements of that in what's going on.
Um,
but I also think that that accessible horsepower is just ripe at the moment.
People are making big power figures and able to warranty it.
That's what it comes down to really.
You know,
I think we would have had 700 horsepower cars many years ago if people could
have genuinely warrantied the engines to that power and not had them blow up.
But they can do it now reliably.
You've also got some,
a lot of electronic systems,
so you can,
you can kind of insert your own,
to come back to that phrase,
the a phrase I use,
net usable horsepower.
You can,
you can insert that really,
I mean a hell cats probably got three it pat actually when you're driving it
because they have two keys.
Exactly.
So one of them gives you like Farleigh I believe it knocks down to 500.
Yeah,
just only 500.
I mean stick isn't it?
Um,
so yeah,
I think the future's going to be exciting.
I think it's worried me for a while.
I don't much like electricity.
Um,
having once twiddled what I thought were two speaker wise when I was about eight
and they turned out to be just plug straight into the mains and come out of the
back of a plug.
And I've got a massive electric shock.
And ever since then I've had a healthy disregard for electricity.
I think it's quite dangerous stuff.
Um,
and it's silent and it's lacking in passion and um,
I don't like it.
I like,
I like burning gasoline.
I hate to say that I do and I think we do it increase in new clever ways,
but it's coming.
It's really,
it's here to stay whether we like it or not.
And I think people like you and I are going to have to decide very soon whether
we can carry on being
current [inaudible] without burning fossil fuels.
Have you fucked around with any of the Teslas or anything like that?
Go?
Not In the new one.
No one's is amazing that you won.
But the four wheel drive one,
no panties,
60 in two seconds.
I mean,
I,
and I,
I'm,
I've had to go in the,
at least based sports car they did early on,
which was remarkable.
I mean it just the talk and the thrust of the little ass.
Yeah.
And you know,
of course it would do about 40 miles on a charge.
I didn't really see the point in that ridiculous.
The balance of having all the batteries are back horrible.
You couldn't,
it was dangerous.
I thought I just,
it was difficult to manage old Porsche Matt style or no,
that's,
we'll get onto that in a minute.
That the whole porch things in their faith,
they're really good.
They're just about managing where the weight is.
Um,
so I think the,
I think the future is actually quite bright.
Uh,
the I eight BMW was the thing that made me the most excited of all the things
I've driven this year.
I got,
I approached the gate with a heavy dose of cynicism.
I thought,
God,
is this the future?
I mean,
if you concentrate on it and you'll never be able to unsee this now it looks
like it's shitting out a nine one one.
It'd be seen that look at the back of it and you'll think it's doing a pool of a
nine one one and you'll never unsee that.
So I've ruined it for you now.
But it's such a clever calm and it,
it somehow takes electricity and fashions it into something that's fun to drive.
Great to be in this clever,
you know,
that's the future.
I'll embrace that.
It's not exactly what I want.
I want to just be in a Hellcat.
I want to be in an rs.
But if you're telling me I can't have that,
then I need to find a solution and I think I can live with that.
And Electricity has its upsides,
you know,
it gives you vast amounts of Torque,
which is really nice.
On the road talk is what matters on the road,
not power.
Um,
so I get,
I I think that I'd have gears.
Yeah.
Um,
I think it's,
I think the future's really quite,
really quite bright and we've,
we've got a passion that can continue for quite a long time.
There it is.
Um,
there you go.
Look at that.
If you look at the back of it or you needed,
is that a wide angle lens?
That's a super wide on it.
Just trying to find better view
down.
You need a square one from the rear.
Yeah.
You can sort of see that left that white one.
Yeah,
that's what I see.
Can you see that?
You see
there's two lights there.
Oh,
I see what you're saying.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
It doesn't vary.
Shitting out of nine 11
does.
Yeah.
That's ugly.
I don't like all the colors.
No,
it's a,
it's a cool thing.
I haven't,
but we tested it here whenever it was earlier in the year and it went from an in
and out burger in it and parked it up and turning up like a rock star.
I could've been in a pink f 40 and people would have ignored me cause that was
there.
It was,
what do you think about these BMW cars that are adding sound that disturbs me on
and coming through the speakers that emulates this,
the sound of an engine.
I've,
I've taken a lot of shit for this cause I've people feel I've been a bit soft on
it.
I don't really mind too much.
The,
the m three is the,
is the guilty as party,
the new one cause gotten in line six and they sort of augmented the noise.
Um,
and he do get some speaking noise that comes at you.
But again,
is that optional?
Can you shut it off?
I think you probably can play with it a bit,
but the really weird one is there's a Renno in the UK where you can choose your
noise so you're in a false that into what happy you and you can make it sound
like a Gtr or a v eight or something.
That's really,
really,
yeah.
That's just odd that,
that's disingenuous.
Um,
so I'm not too,
I'm not too hard on it.
I,
I'm,
I've always been more about the dynamics of these things and the moment that you
start to get too caught up in the noise in an era where turbocharging is going
to be the norm,
you know,
you can forget about normal aspiration really from now on.
Um,
there'll be a few last bastions of it,
but the new four or five eight will be turbocharge.
Um,
yeah,
the moment you get to hit up with noise,
I think you're in trouble.
I think you could find things to not enjoy about cars.
Um,
noises it is,
it's so,
it's so important but that you apply a turbocharger and you totally bollocksed
that intake noise and then really all you can do is fit loud exhaust.
And I think I love about your car is that the intake and exhaust to quite close
together,
the two noises blend together to give you something really,
really special.
But it's the intake noise on your car but is actually what does it for me,
it's what I'm hearing in the car.
And that is all the top of the engine.
That's all where it's coming in.
That's where it's breathing in the exhaling bit.
You're leaving all that behind.
Right?
So I am,
I'm one for more intake,
noise in cars,
give me proper intake noise.
Um,
and I think that's what they're,
they're going to do more and more is they've gone down this route of faking the
noise and they'd been,
broadly speaking,
not,
not getting a great response from people.
So what,
I think it will start doing his tubing noise directly into the cabin and some
people have tried it,
Mclaren have done it and I think for did it as well.
Will you just take a little chew right off the top of the engine by the intake
is and just feed it into the cabin.
It's quite clever.
Um,
but yeah,
noise is very important for me,
but it's so important that if it's not right,
I almost want to just forget about it and not get too involved in the,
in the discussion that what you need to know about the n three is just brilliant
and it's just a great car.
Um,
and they didn't really need to do that.
The m five is even weirder.
We'd been in a new m five or what the current hand?
Five.
Well,
that's strange because the noise that makes fluctuates with the speakers,
so it sounds like a different car at different points in the rev range,
but at low revs it sounds like a four cylinder because of the firing order of
the engine.
And then when you get up at a little bit it starts to sound like a Subaru
Impressa.
So it sounds like a flat fall.
And then when you go a bit further,
it sounds a bit more like an Audi quatro.
Sounds like an ERC,
quatro,
a five cylinder,
and then at the top end starts to sound a bit like an old [inaudible] 39 m five
v eight which is strange.
And I think it really harms the personality of the car because it's a shape
shifter.
It has these four different sound personalities and you don't really,
you don't really engage with any of them.
You just think,
well that's weird.
Oh,
it's in,
it's being a quattro at the moment.
What about the m six grand copay?
Oh,
that's a car,
isn't it?
July?
Like,
it looks like a monster.
I love the way it looks.
I like it better than this.
The the two door,
four door grand pay looks.
It just has like a personality that the two door,
it looks goofy.
You know,
it's like there's some two door cars that used to be afforded or like I love the
two door s class.
There's the new ones love new.
It's amazing.
It looks like a spaceship.
I mean it looks really incredible but there's something about the m six it's
always been kind of goofy look into so you don't like the new one.
I liked the grand coupe.
Pay The floor,
not the coop.
I don't mind.
Yeah I don't mind the coop.
I I think the grand pay is just elegant,
gorgeous,
low riding.
I mean if you,
if you asked me what I thought a modern Jaguar big saloon car should be,
I might almost give you a picture of the m six grand coupe cause it is just got
that sort of low seating position.
Low roof line,
impossibly long loads of power.
Interiors.
Yeah.
Great to drive as well.
I'm in the fizzle rosters.
Fuck we did.
I think we did 8.6 to 100 miles an hour in it.
That's just,
that's just crazy.
We did a drag race against all the other competition.
It just mauled all of the AMG.
Yeah.
It's really fast.
Very efficient transmission in that,
that,
how about this?
The ride quality?
Um,
too much.
Obviously he doesn't tense.
But then two,
two,
four p for me.
But you shouldn't ask me about the two things.
You shouldn't ask me about riding a ride quality because I expect really good.
Right.
I don't think ride and handling are,
um,
you know,
I don't think they are
separate entities.
I think they,
I think you can have one on the other.
I think they're absolutely workable.
You know,
it has to be managed by electronics though.
Well,
no,
he just,
it's just expensive suspension components,
you know.
The fact is that the bits that you don't see on a car,
the bits they don't spend money on.
So the damper unit on,
uh,
on,
and sexy,
probably not that expensive.
You know,
if you took it to a rally team and said,
what would you do with it?
They'd just laugh at you and go,
we'd fit proper damper to at first so you can,
you know,
the green car that we come back to,
that port on 11 we built.
The whole point was it had this suppleness about it had world rally car dampers
on it.
So it was from and supportive when you needed it to be.
And then the moment that you wanted to go over a rough road,
it had lots of compliance and wheelchair,
but it was lovely.
Um,
so that's the one thing that has me about ride because I'll bore you for fucking
hours about ride and,
and looks to come back to what you just said,
I can't judge a cars looked publicly privately.
I can,
I can tell you what I think is nice,
nasty,
but I'm not the arbiter of what looks good.
You can see I'm wearing a yellow t shirt that costs a pound by just don't give a
fuck about the way I look.
And I just,
I therefore,
I don't think I have the right to judge the way things look.
I can tell you to like,
I mean subjectively you'll,
you look at uh,
a grand cool pay.
That's a beautiful quote I do myself.
I think it's a lot better looking than the m four I within my,
within my trade.
It's not valid for me to say this car is a great looking car.
Why not?
Because it's up to the individual and I said to you,
to me,
yeah,
of course.
To me that's fine.
My,
my opinion's valid to me I think on aesthetics,
but you know,
there are people out there,
the thing that the Panto as to it looks good and they're there.
They have every right to think that.
I mean,
I think the property,
a friend who loves the AMG station wagon.
Yeah.
I mean he wants to get one.
Which one?
The big one doing.
I Dunno,
the clause.
I don't know.
I don't know which one it is.
I like,
I quite like those sort of wagon is just so cool.
See,
I love wagons.
Wow.
I've got an rs six wagon.
Yeah.
I,
that's why I drive.
I drive an io six.
Why wouldn't you?
It's just the coolest thing because I've got,
I've got a big dog and I've got three kids,
so I couldn't have an rx seven.
It wouldn't be confused.
I don't mind an SUV.
Do you don't like it?
I don't like wagons.
I'm,
I'm leaving because
I think
in the church they call that schism.
Um,
so I love wagons.
I love the,
I love combining all those disciplines in a car.
I liked the fact that my Rsx,
we'll go on a photo shoot and chase a Mclaren p one for two days pretty well
too.
And then on the way back it will go and collect three kids from school.
And then after that I'll stick the dog on it and we'll go up into the hills and
go for a walk.
So I like multidisciplined cars.
So if I look at,
go back to the portfolio of cars,
if you left me with one car,
it'd be an Rsx at the moment.
Yeah,
because,
because it just,
the new one,
the old one was terrible.
The new one.
Brilliant.
I just think it's genius.
What do you think of uh,
the um,
the Audi a s eight.
The new one?
Yes.
I have not driven the new one,
but it's got I think which engines the new s eight got some retarded amount of
power.
I think it's got the same engine that I've got in my rs six 570 horsepower or
something.
Yeah.
That these VW group enters is difficult to keep a track on where they are coming
from,
what power they've got.
I think it shares the Bentley engine,
so the engine in my rs six and they've gables.
The whole powertrain is straight out of the Va Bentley continental gt,
but it's miles better than it is in the Bentley I think.
Really?
I don't know.
It just seems to work better.
Suits the carpet.
I Dunno.
Maybe the calibration is better.
I can't answer that really.
I think,
yeah,
the essay to fight driven and this is the thing,
I'm not getting old and I am,
I is my brain sometimes I can't remember what I've driven.
Sometimes we're having so many cars,
something will come up and say,
do you remember the whatever and ever,
have you driven the s class Mercedes s class coupé yet?
No,
we're doing that in January,
the 63 as well.
It looks amazing.
I think that's a beautiful looking car.
One of the best cars I've ever made as far as looks.
It's incredible.
And the interiors amazing now.
I think in some ways it kind of defeats the purpose of the s class and not have
a usable backseat.
It kind of has one,
but you know the,
the feet are going to be bunched up in the ride quality.
I'm sure it's probably pretty similar,
but it's not the same length wheelbase.
Right,
but that car can,
that can stomach a slightly for them.
A ride can't,
it's a different purpose.
It's a gt car more.
Yeah,
I think so.
And apparently the story behind the rear seats was they just did a customer
clinic and said,
how many of you use the rear seats?
People that buy our cars and they all went,
we just lift the sea and throw a bag in the back.
That's what we do with the seats.
They went,
okay,
we'll just not have receipts then really it's just a classic piece of customer
clinic.
And he could be very dangerous when you customer clinic cars cause you can't
fuck things up is known in the past.
Like the five,
seven,
five Ferrari.
That was a fucked up five 50 because it,
they went to the customers and said,
so you've all got five fifties,
how would you know,
what do you want in your new car when we,
if we're doing a new one,
I'm not saying we're doing anyone,
but if we do a new one,
what would you like it?
And they all said,
well,
um,
we want these paddles because your f one drivers have got them and they're
really cool.
So we won the paddles and we want more power when we come out of the pay homage
in San Rafael.
We want more pay powered on your fast and,
and also the five 50 quite bumpy,
you know,
when we're on road.
So can need to make it less bumpy.
And so what Freud did was they gave it a paddle shift.
Um,
and they gave it low more power and talk and they softened the hell out of it to
make it a bit more comfortable.
And of course the thing was just fucking undrivable cause it,
it was so loose,
it wasn't,
didn't have nice ride,
it just had a lack of control.
And the first time we drove it honors of Welsh be road,
we just ripped the front of the car off.
It just kept bottoming out and it just tore the front off the car.
So,
um,
a Freud didn't like that.
Um,
and then in light of what we said about it,
I remember,
and then about five months later having said to us,
we don't listen to what you say,
you'll just journalists,
our customers know best.
They um,
they have,
they announced this thing called the fear on OPAC,
which was like upgraded springs dampers and just fixed all of the problems.
I want a manual gearbox option as well.
Well you went from having a Porsche Rs,
the 4.0 and then you went,
did you get a five,
nine,
nine?
I had to figure out a five,
nine.
I mean,
that's,
that goes down in history,
doesn't it as possibly the worst financial move ever.
I couldn't believe you did that.
First of all.
First of all,
get rid of like one of the greatest Porsche's ever.
We agreed we weren't going to talk about that.
It's just not fair.
You can't remind me of that.
That's like saying,
it's like me saying yes to,
you know,
your girlfriend was Heidi Klum or something,
isn't it?
They remind me of that.
You got rid of one of the greatest cars ever that's worth so much money now.
That's the crazy thing,
right?
How much are they worth now?
I saw one for sale for 275,000 American.
Oh,
they're worth much more than that.
Yeah.
In the UK they're worth well over $350,000.
Wow.
Um,
so I did a right out of mine.
Hey look,
I,
I take a very philosophical view about this stuff.
I got to own a 40 TRS.
I did things with it that not many people that own fully is,
have done.
I did big journeys.
I used it a lot.
There's a video of it still up on youtube of it being driven in a completely
ludicrous manner.
That was my car.
Um,
it made me money.
That was a pretty nice thing to happen.
And at the time I didn't have any money,
you know,
I bet the House on that thing I used the last bit of cash,
I had to put the down,
I didn't meet the finance criteria from Porsche,
so I had to beg,
steal and borrow to get them to lend me the money.
And then the payments were well over £1,000 a month and I wasn't earning much
money at the time,
so I couldn't really afford it.
I sort of kept going for,
I think we had it for a year and a bit and then I just had the set age.
It was just basic economics.
I couldn't afford the finance.
But then after that,
about six months after that,
I started earning a bit more money.
I had a couple of contracts that were quite good.
I had a bit of money.
And of course the medical condition means the moment you've got money,
you go straight out and buy a car,
don't you?
I didn't need a five nine nine it was absolute nonsense.
It cost me a fortune.
I lost a load of money.
I'm probably lost half the money I'd made on the port in it,
but I'd always wanted a five nine nine I,
I'm I view life is a series of boxes to tick.
Okay.
And it's quite binary.
It's just a series of ones and noughts and that's what I want to do.
And the 42 box has been ticked.
I don't,
I don't really derive any pleasure from sitting and telling a room full of
people that I've got a 42 IRS.
I wouldn't,
I derive pleasure from driving it.
But once I had driven it quite a bit,
I can't kind of done it,
you know,
and I'm,
I'm lucky in that I can kind of use them to the,
to the full extent of their abilities.
That's a nice thing to know that you can do that.
You've driven a 42 IRS to 100% of his ability as a nice thing to know.
And I'd done that.
And then I thought I quite like a five,
nine,
nine and then I had had the five,
nine for a year and realized that it was actually just too big and too fast for
UK rose,
but I tick that box and then the next box to tick was probably a five 12 tr or
something like that or an m three or uh,
there's just so much out there.
It's a bit like walking into a bookshop.
You need to know where to start.
And I love that about the subjects I've got caught endlessly fascinating and
looking for the next thing that I want to enjoy.
I've got a massive problem with Mercedes 500 ears at the moment.
You know,
the,
the old w one two four shape from the,
from the early nineties.
I W I will end up really?
Yeah,
I'll end up having one of those in the next six months because I just can't help
it.
I mean there's a few things that will remain permanent in my life.
I'll never sell that to CV cause it's just so cool.
Um,
and also financially I can probably afford,
you know,
if I get to the stage where I have to sell the two CV,
I'm fucked it so badly that I'm over anyway.
I'll keep my m five my eight 28 and five,
I wouldn't ever sell that.
And I think everything else,
86,
one of the very early ones,
a squared off one.
Um,
I think everything else is for sale always.
I don't,
I don't feel I've got a two oh five little little citron,
sorry,
a little Persia.
That is a worth no money at all.
But I think I'd struggle to get rid of that.
Everything else is for sale.
Always will be.
And,
and it as for sale at a loss.
If I need to move on to the next thing to,
to have a go,
I'm just starting to develop a thing for two generations ago is m three not the
last one,
which I have.
I have,
I know the Va,
I have the v eight one,
but the one before that,
the 46 333 horsepower one,
that's the car that I think if you,
if you wrote down all the disciplines that an m three needs needs to be good at,
that's probably the best one they ever made.
I think some respects is nicer than the Va.
It's a beautiful car too.
I love the shape of it.
It's a classic shape,
understated but very nice.
And it's so you can find out a nice,
a nice face lift car with the face lift dash with the big sat nav and the 18
inch wheels or smaller wheels and a manual obviously get rid of those paddles.
And I think that then is,
that's a seriously lovely car.
And did you,
you didn't get the CSL here,
did you?
Um,
which ones that don't think you did.
They did a special lightweight car which didn't come here actually get that a
carbon roof.
Um,
carbon intake,
bit more power,
full track with pilot Sport Cup standard.
And they launched in o three o four.
They're now very valuable.
They're going up.
That's a really nice car.
Type in m three CS.
The death of the manuals are often talked about subject,
but it kind of an important one because when we're talking about sound being
important,
like sound in a car like that,
but shifting your own gears is important too.
There's something that's missing.
I have the,
my BMW is a double clutch and I like it cause the traffic cause allies,
traffic's brutal.
It's a good car to just,
it's my commuter car,
but there's something missing.
Something really missing.
Yeah,
that's it.
If you get the rear shot of it,
you'll see it had a special boot lid with a sort of kicked up ducktail on the
boot.
So really,
really good looking car.
You look at,
there you go.
Yeah,
that's different.
Oh I have seen those stuff at the back and they're really special.
You know the man,
the manual gearbox is very,
very interesting.
Manual in America is very common and it's almost all,
all the big sports cars in America,
whether it's a corvette or the z 28 they all have manual options.
The new Mustang there,
the Shelby gt three 50 that's coming out.
That will be a manual as well.
Um,
I think burrs,
I think the world owes the u s a debt for still wanting manuals over here.
Without you guys wanting them,
there'd be a lot less.
You've also had some cars 50 with manual transmissions that we haven't,
so being there'll be m five over here you can buy as a shifter and the
[inaudible] and the m six,
but we can't,
there's just us only they,
even the grand coupe pay is available as a stick.
I know.
And that's,
I suppose horses.
Oh,
okay.
The manual thing I could talk about for too long.
So I'll try and be brief as you can tell.
I get a little bit of a kid stuff.
So can we brief,
okay.
So the,
the first,
the first point is that the manual gearbox is wonderful.
It's an integral part of driving,
controlling the vehicle,
um,
your buisiness behind the wheel,
the things that you're active doing.
You know,
one of the most important is,
is shifting gear and the process of learning to shift gear properly of healing
and towing of,
of,
of controlling a vehicle.
That's,
that's something very personal between you and the machine.
It's something that you can take pride in.
Um,
and I love that.
I think that's integral to driving.
However,
if you live in La and you're stuck in traffic,
I wouldn't have a manual.
I'd want an automatic.
So it's horses for courses,
isn't it?
If I'd say for your hobby car,
for the car that you enjoy it.
Weekends,
I can't see why you'd ever want anything other than manual.
I think you'd be a bit of a masochist if you want to just sit in a traffic jam
in a manual nine,
nine,
seven turboed heavy clutch,
just be horrible.
Um,
but the manual gearbox and the future of it,
it's an interesting subject.
I think that the manual gearbox is and is going to be a bit like vinyl records.
So vinyl records have suddenly exploded in sales.
You've been reading about that.
So everyone's back into vinyl.
There's always been a subculture that I was vinyl.
I am,
I've always been one of those are quite like a bit of vinyl.
I like the sound.
I like just like the tactility of it all.
It's lovely.
And also reminds you of when you were a kid going to buy an album,
doesn't it?
It's lovely.
Um,
and I think the manual gear box is going to be a bit like that.
So what's going to happen is you'll see this,
it will be continued to phase out and manufacturers will make fewer and fewer of
them and then someone's going to go,
do you know what?
I can see a market here.
We can make a limited run of manual whatevers.
So if the,
if,
say Porsche took the nine one one gt three and they've said publicly,
that's one of the big cars that everyone wants a manual gearbox in.
But they didn't give one did,
they just gave paddles only and everyone said,
the commentators said that no one's going to buy it.
It's not a manual.
Of course they sold every gt three.
They could,
I can make,
um,
but if feel if porter turned around and said,
we're going to make a limited run of manual gearbox gt three,
but they're going to be $100,000 more than the standard car and we're only going
to make 500 of them,
they'd sell them overnight.
They just would sell them overnight.
You just know they would because there's enough people out there.
And I think what will happen is that they will be a kind of,
there will be a subculture of manual transmissions and know and some money for
how many fractures will endorse it and some won't.
But I think you'll find that if the numbers stack up,
what if they turned around and said,
we could engineer a manual gearbox for,
uh,
for the new four,
five,
eight Ferrari,
but it's going to cost you $150,000 more.
Exactly.
Really it's just market forces.
If,
if they can create a business case for doing it,
they will do it.
I just cannot understand why they haven't,
I can understand why they haven't released the four or five,
eight and the GT three.
I just don't understand it.
So many people want it in a manual.
Two things.
It's um,
it's economies of scale there.
These are small volume products and they require quite expensive good
transmissions.
You can't just bolt in your kit gearbox that you've got in five other models,
you know,
you,
you've got to have a proper transmission and they're expensive,
proper transmissions.
Um,
and its emissions.
It's a big problem with the missions because you,
when you,
the admissions cycle certainly in,
in,
in Europe are there a bit of a con everyone knows what you've got to be doing at
certain points in the rev range and how you can cheat your way around it.
And if you've got a seven or eight speed dual clutch transmission,
that shifts itself,
you can really work the cycle beautifully to get some very clever results for
your emissions.
Whereas if you've got a manual is much,
much more difficult to get the results.
So you,
you tend to that they play slightly fast and loose with the rules and that's why
it's,
it's as much the mission space as it is cost base.
So I think we'll probably lose them a bit again.
Okay.
This I'd greet manual gearboxes in with vinyl and chronometer in a sort of
standard wine up chronometer watchers,
you know,
in the 80s who had a chronometer watch.
No one did the day,
you know,
and um,
but suddenly they were back in fashion.
Now aren't they?
People want watches that cost 10,000 pounds and don't actually keep time.
Yeah,
there's soccer cute.
I can see,
I think the manual gearbox will become a sort of art and product that certain
brands will buy into and we'll supply you at a cost.
I'm secretly hoping that the IRS has an a manual option.
You want to be disappointed?
I don't know for sure,
but I can,
yeah,
it's not,
it's too expensive for a series of cars,
you know,
it's not going to be there.
Have you got your name down for one?
I don't know.
And also I would want it to be a six speed.
I think that the seven speed is from everything that I've heard.
Seven.
It was goofy.
Yeah.
The original seven speed manual in the nine on one is bad to the point where I'd
actually have a PDK car I think.
And even though I always would want a manual nine 11 I didn't like the seven
speed.
However,
they've just reengineered the seven speed in the new 901 gts,
which they launched last month.
And everyone I've spoken to who I trust says it's totally transformed.
The new seven speed is proper.
They've made it good.
So what was missing in the old one,
but it was the shift quality wasn't very nice cause what they did is they
basically packed a manual transmission into the PDK case.
So it's effectively a PDK that you're operating manually was not just not Jill
clutch,
but it's in the same case.
And that meant that the shift was a bit funny.
So the first and second planes were,
we're good.
Second and third was fine once you,
so second,
third,
first and second was fine.
Second and third and fourth were fine.
But when you got to fifth and sixth it was slightly off angle.
It wasn't quite right.
So fifth to sixth sick was back towards you a bit.
If you're in a left hand drive car and then seventh was a way and up,
it wasn't quite symmetrical and therefore if you wanted to go seventh back to
fifth and just pop it back and let the spring then put you up into fifth you
didn't always get fit or weren't always quite sure where it was you could do and
sick God,
this is a proper geeky conversation,
isn't it?
And sick for seventh to sixth was quite unsatisfactory,
a shift.
It was sort of had a resistance to it.
Now I think they've probably got them all straightened out and it's much more
precise and decisive.
They've not driven it,
but everyone loves the shift quality of life.
The Boxster,
the Boxster,
and the Cayman being the six speed.
Like why talk writing isn't it?
It's talking to those.
Those gearboxes are probably at the limit of talk and also the obviously the,
the other way around it,
it's a,
it's a mid engine car.
The gear box is on the other side,
so you can't just bolt it on their design course.
They could do it.
They that it's just the money thing.
It's just a money thing really just seems so wrong to have an rs and only have
panel shift.
What do you think to the shift on your car?
Cause some people prefer the slightly longer slicker shift of the Cayman and the
box to the IRS.
It's quite Nachi the IRS gearbox,
I dunno.
It's perfect.
Whatever it is.
It's just every time I drive another car I drive that car.
I'm like,
this car is like the most tactile,
the most connected car I've ever driven.
It's just so fun.
I just love it.
Is it heavily modded jaws?
Chassis wise?
Yeah.
It's pretty modded.
It's a little lower.
A little stiffer,
but it's just,
it's so awesome.
It's the best car I've ever owned.
502 did you do with the engine in it when you bought it?
WHATSAPP.
Do you have the engine done?
What was it?
Did He,
no,
I had it done.
I saw obviously the painful question.
How much is d something for the whole deal?
Yeah.
You see a buy an rs for a hundred plus and then he sent it to him and spend
another 60 on it.
So they modify your existing engine or was it new engine?
It's the existing engine is a 3.6.
Yeah.
He take it out.
It takes it out and pours it out and the whole deal,
it takes a few months.
I'm going to have headers put on it now and that will bump it up.
Another 18 horsepower.
You who changed the sound a little bit?
It
did it feel noticeably quicker.
Straight away.
Uh,
I didn't even buy the 3.6.
I know I bought the 3.6 and headed immediately sent to them.
I never drove it.
I never touched it.
I had a gen two gt three,
the standard a gt three.
Uh,
I really enjoyed it.
But then I found out about the,
um,
the RS shark works car and I was like,
I gotta have one of those.
So you sold the Gen two,
3.8 and then bought the water.
Had it immediately sent to Alex at chark works.
Have you driven the 4.1 yet?
I've not driven either that or engines.
Everyone says their sensation.
Good Golly,
Miss Molly.
The 3.9 that I have is amazing.
The 4.1,
it's just another,
so I'm coming back end of January.
Can we go?
Yes.
We'll go and I'll set it up on the Twitter.
So I see him on the Twitter.
He's a great guy.
You'll love Alex.
He's awesome.
He'll be here on the ninth on uh,
uh yeah.
On January 9th they're coming to La.
What about,
so they based 0.1,
he's in northern California,
like up near South San Francisco.
So that Friday the 9th of January that coming down.
Matt Farris going to be here.
If you guys still get along by then.
We don't always get to that.
But this drive thing we'll get,
well I thought,
what can I have a cigarette and then we'll have a chat about the drive thing.
Sure.
Yeah.
Is that all right?
What time is it?
Four 30 you can have a cigarette in here if you like.
We'll just turn on the air filter.
We have a felt just disgusting.
It's okay.
People do it all the time.
Yeah.
Have one.
Crank that sucker up.
Aching.
Is that what it is?
You get that achy cigarette thing?
No,
I'm a,
I'm a reformed smoker who I've just lapsed a bit in the last month or two.
Do we have any more coffee,
Jamie?
No,
it's fine.
Drink does not.
Yeah.
What do you want about bubbles in it collects water.
That was one that,
that's a weird Marlboro pack.
If they're black,
what is that?
I think what that clicky ice blasting on them.
Oh,
I love that clicky ice blast.
Really strong here.
Mental.
Have you tried them or,
I'd be talking about menthol.
Ice Blast and you do it on demand.
You Click it on demand a mouthwash.
So you quit for how long and you got back into it.
So have a seat,
man.
Don't worry about it.
Yeah,
I'm on and off,
but I'm,
I'm no,
I've been good for ages and I shouldn't,
no,
he shouldn't be saying this because I don't want my children.
No,
no smokes.
Do you ever try to fuck
around with those electronic cigarettes?
No,
I can't see any point in that tool.
The nicotine like that.
It's like a sugar free drink.
What's the point?
Yeah,
I like the,
I like having a beer and a fag in my hand.
It's just seems so natural in America.
It's known as a cigarette and a fag is a derogatory expression for homosexual.
Can call it a fake.
I don't wear a fanny pack and I walk on.
I do.
Where am I?
What pavement or sidewalk?
Either one.
I don't give a fuck.
I'm American
pavements sidewalk,
whatever you want to call it.
Hood Trunk.
The whole lexicon of cartoons is a real problem for me because hood,
the,
I spend too much time in America.
I start calling things hoods and talking about sedans.
It's a fucking sedan.
It's saloon car saloon car.
Yeah.
I had to learn all that stuff.
And I watched your shows from top gear on.
And what about fifth gear?
Does anybody give a fuck about that anymore?
I'll hope so.
I'm,
I'm on an episode soon.
So can you give a fuck about it?
The tifs of legend,
the legend.
So Tif,
I grew up watching tiff.
You know,
he was probably one of the reasons we wanted to do this cause he's just mega and
I used to remember watching those top guests gets.
So he's the one that can actually drive why and the woman on the car,
what is the woman on the show?
She can try as well.
She's the only woman on car shows that they should put me as a shit goes
sideways around corners.
If there's any really,
really fast female drivers that want to do car videos that they,
can you drop me an email please?
Because that's the next thing.
Even if you could put a really good looking girl in a Mclaren p one,
that video wouldn't be four and a half million.
It'd be 10 million.
She had to wear like a bikini or she could,
no,
it doesn't need to be perfect.
It doesn't need to be like one of those Gti videos where they've topless and you
know they're not hitting them in the face.
It doesn't need to be like that,
but just,
I think people prefer this,
the aesthetic of the woman to the man,
understandably so.
Of course there are better looking at us.
It's a fact.
Even women like the way the women look.
But I did a shoot with tiff,
so I did.
Um,
yeah,
that's another subject I did.
Um,
I did a sh we just done a shoot with,
with,
um,
with tiff for fifth gear and Jesus,
what the guy can really drive.
He is the real deal,
you know,
it gets in the car,
but he's not even driven before and the camera man says,
can you put it there sideways,
you know,
four feet that way.
And he just does it on point.
They're done.
Bang,
gone.
Can I have a coffee now?
Please.
He knows how to drive for sure that he's an absolute legend and a wicked bloat.
Spend time with as well.
He's,
he's,
he's the real deal.
Yeah.
He seems like he would be,
he's a,
he's fun as well.
And so that show,
uh,
is that a BBC show as well?
No,
that's not going to work then.
Yeah,
I think it's been,
it might be a discovery show.
It's been on discovery for a while,
but I don't think the one I did as until April or something like that.
But I've done,
so what I've done is they track battle with,
with tiff in a couple of cars,
um,
at Castle Combe in the UK is really,
really good fun to work with them.
But it sort of,
for me it was an eye opener.
I partly wanted to do it because I get to work with tiff.
That was,
if you'd said to me when I was 15 that I would shoot a sort of extreme driving
scene on a with
tiff.
I just said,
no way will that ever happen.
Um,
and I wanted to see how the TV process works as well because we,
we shoot a very particular way.
We're completely renegade.
I just have this,
you know,
Neal,
who is the guy that I shoot with is like my,
you know,
my fifth limb,
he's,
he's everything.
He shoots everything,
he edits everything.
He's a genius.
He's just a great guy and we're hyper efficient.
We don't get much time to do these things.
We just get given an hour and I try it normally and we'd just cobble it together
as quickly as possible and then fire it out there and people watch it and they
seem to enjoy it.
TV has more time and it's more laborious.
And I think,
I think TV could learn a lot from what we do.
And equally I think there's still some stuff we can learn from TV and hopefully
over the next couple of years we'll refine the process into something that can
not only be enjoyable but earn us some money as well.
So you were,
you were going to have your cigarette and you were going to talk about drive and
for folks who don't know what's going on,
drives a channel that was on youtube and then drive morphed into drive plus,
which happened right when I filmed a,
they filmed the,
the shark works ones with my car and the 4.1 liter and it became a pay channel
drive plus became something that you paid for and the Internet revolted.
There was a a gigantic backlash.
People got very upset.
If you look at the comments of the drive video that I did it,
almost all of them were complaining about drive plus even though the drive
video,
there's a three,
whatever it was,
five minute drive,
one which was free and then at 15 minute,
whatever it was,
drive plus,
which you had to pay for.
Yeah.
The,
the,
the drive.
Um,
well this isn't really about drive.
This is about the Internet and this is about content and,
and whether people are willing to pay for it and where the content worth
anything.
I mean the Internet is an amazing thing,
but it's also deeply evil for content producers like you and I.
Um,
because it's created a precedent where people think everything should be free,
but there's a cost to producing stuff.
I mean,
understandably the overheads for us doing this or a lot less than going out to a
track,
hiring a track wrecking tires,
putting fuel in a car,
you know,
it's not a cheap process.
It costs money to do it.
And because it costs money to do it,
you need to find a way of remunerating yourself against that.
So you either advertise against the content and get as many views as you can.
And if that fails,
which has happened on Youtube now quite publicly,
you need to find a way of making money.
So you have to try and charge for the content.
So how has it,
how has it failed?
What happened?
Well,
I don't think it's failed actually.
It's still going.
I just,
I'm not part of that now because for my particular type of videos,
it was a struggle for me to do it because I needed to be doing a lot of views to
keep the car industry interest interested in what I was doing.
And I go from doing a couple hundred thousand views to doing 20,000 views and
then go back to Porsche and say,
can I drive the new rs when it comes out?
And they'll go,
well you need to do 20,000 views,
so why would you be on our list of people to drive the car?
So that kind of means that I struggled to get in the product and ultimately I'm
a product review or that's the basis of what I do.
Okay.
Broadly speaking,
it's entertainment.
It's just about the skidding cars around having fun.
And I think it's a sort of a new world now with Internet journalists that didn't
exist before.
I mean,
so the,
the numbers are essentially the only thing that justify this new world to these
old school businesses.
Yeah,
they,
they view youtube as being something new and amazing and,
and rightly so.
And we've,
we've sold it to them as being that.
And then we turned around quite early in the process.
They've just adopted it and taken it as being something they want to be a part
of.
And then suddenly we're saying,
actually we can't carry on doing it this way.
They're not earning enough money.
I remember talking to someone at Porsche saying,
it must be great.
You must be getting a lot of dollar of you.
I'm wrong.
No,
no,
we're not.
So that hasn't quite worked.
I think the drive,
I think the drive plus experiment is ongoing.
I don't think it's failed.
And I think actually it might be,
I think people might view it in a couple of years time as being quite smart
move.
Um,
but it just wasn't smart for me within the portfolio.
So I had,
I had to do something about it.
I had to get back out there again with free to air films and find another way of
monetizing it.
Um,
and I think that's what I'm trying to do at the moment.
That's,
you know,
it's nothing evil.
It's,
you know,
so what are you doing now?
So we've got another youtube channel which sits in its own space,
just called Chris Harris on cars.
And I'm just putting my normal films out of the way I used to for free.
Um,
but I've got to find new ways of interacting with brands to get them to sponsor
the channel,
to get them to work with us and give us some money so we can,
we can keep it,
you know,
free to air.
And that means everything from car brands to normal sponsorship.
You have a much more sophisticated sponsorship model over here.
People are much more willing to come and spend money around electronic content
in the U S and they are in Europe.
It's still difficult to get people to spend money around electronic content in,
in,
in Europe certainly is what I find.
Well,
the United States in the podcast world,
it's only been over the last three years or so that we've had advertisers that
are willing to get interested in it or willing to get involved.
And over the last year or two it's actually gotten kind of crazy where they're
realizing the numbers.
The numbers are just so gigantic.
They're as big,
if not bigger than very successful cable shows.
So the amount of money that they can spend to reach,
especially my show,
which I,
I personally pick and choose all the advertisers,
like I reject as many advertisers as I accept because I just don't want,
I don't believe that the product or I don't want to be involved in the product
or I can't see it working.
It's not something I want to support.
Whatever.
The reason is if I decide to get behind something like a Squarespace or whatever
our ads are,
I know it's a solid product.
I know I have no remorse whatsoever.
No guilt about about,
uh,
having that product,
a sponsor,
the show.
But this wasn't the case just a few years ago.
There was just,
it wasn't,
it wasn't that much.
We were doing it almost all just for fun in the beginning.
Yeah.
I'm and I'm,
it's,
it's so much more advanced than it is in the video world.
I mean,
I'm now on this patrion thing,
which that's,
that's fascinating.
Patrion is like a donation
based thing.
So when we did drug costs,
a lot of people said a lot of the comments that came back that were,
were sensible.
Where were people saying,
look,
I love what you do,
but I don't want to subscribe.
I don't want to,
I don't want to feel bound into a subscription.
It's not something I'm comfortable with.
Have you thought of a donation?
And I'm thinking it's just really weird because it,
it's,
it's a,
it's a service.
It's a product.
You know,
if I go into a shop and I want to buy a copy of evo magazine,
I fully expect to have to pay for it.
I don't just walk into the shop,
pick it up and walk out again.
So,
so the idea of sort of donation box seemed a bit strange,
but I have signed up to it in the last three weeks.
And bless all of you out there that have contributed.
I mean I think it's up to about $3,000 a month is what people are willing to
Tonese.
Yeah.
And it's,
and it's carrying on and we know we're not going to play fast and loose with
that.
That is going to help us fund more content.
That's basically going to pay Neil.
So thank you.
Well thank you on behalf of Neal.
Is the money public the amount public like yes,
you can go on there and see it's all public.
You can go on there and see how much is being,
so then people can look at it and go,
oh fuck him,
he's getting 3000 a month.
I'm not going to give him shit.
Well,
yeah,
cause I mean I don't help myself to I because at the end of the day,
you know,
the one hand I have got a Ferrari,
I can't hide that.
I'm always wasting money on cars.
And then I'm saying,
can I have some money to help me make videos?
But that is,
you know,
in life,
personal cash doesn't last long in the commercial world and if you start sort of
applying sums of money that you can live off into video productions,
the two don't square with each other.
They're quite different things,
not at all.
Um,
so yeah,
I'm,
I think that the Internet video space is going to change radically over the next
even 12 months.
I think there is already a lot fewer players in there were even two years ago,
you know,
two years ago it was,
all the buff books in the u s had their video channels and we're out putting one
or two videos a week,
maybe more in some cases in motor trend were rampant doing some great content
and loads of it where they're doing nothing like as much.
Now,
current driver,
we're more cautious and didn't do quite as much,
but they're doing,
you know,
not so much now as well.
And I think you're gonna find a lot of players,
big publishers are looking at it and saying,
well,
what's in this for us?
You know,
we don't make any money out of it.
We're actually losing money.
Why are we going to carry on doing it?
Um,
and I think the outrage at drive going to drive plus was,
was simply the fact that we had allowed people to get drunk on,
on a product for free.
And maybe it was disingenuous as a,
at the start to say,
this is going to be free forever.
You know,
I just,
I can't see how it could be if you can't earn the money back from it and
advertising,
you have to stop.
It's quite simple.
Yeah.
That's just the thing about the internet.
If you,
if drive plus just have drive just went away and didn't come back as dry.
Plus it just became some new entity that charged money.
Maybe people would have a different approach to it.
But people get so used to things being free.
I know maybe that was wrong and it may make,
you know,
maybe we all made mistakes and I certainly,
I made some mistakes in the process.
I'm not going to go into that side of things.
Um,
but you know,
I don't bear any grudge to anyone is in developing it and needing money while
developing it.
You know,
like needing to pay a salary while development.
If you were independently wealthy and you were pursuing this whole thing and
then you would probably eventually figure out some sort of a sponsorship model
that would make money because the content is excellent,
the show is excellent and it's a matter of like just getting the right amount of
eyes on it to get people to sponsor it where it's a substantial amount of money
that can pay for production and salaries and everything.
It's a full distribution model as well.
That's,
that's actually the core flaw is that youtube is a wonderful thing.
Um,
and has an enormous audience,
but they keep such a large percentage of the revenue that comes in from
advertising that it's almost some workable.
I mean,
you know,
you're giving away 40% straight away,
um,
and the sums aren't great.
And of course then there's thing called the ad blocker,
which is,
you know,
if you,
if you dropped an alien down into planet earth and said,
this is the business model,
they'd say,
what's a home?
The minute you spend all your money making the films,
40% leaves you straight away and there is software widely available that allows
people to actually block the adverts that are supporting what you're trying to
sell.
So,
you know,
you are completely taken away at the shins before you've even started.
Isn't it possible to do ads inside the video itself?
Yes,
but that's,
that's,
you know,
then,
then you're into slightly grey area with youtube because then they're the losers
because they're saying,
well,
hang on a minute.
If you're advertising within the show,
we don't see any of that revenue.
And yet we're hosting your videos.
Do they do that?
Did they say,
did they do well?
There are rules around it obviously,
and quite understandably so,
but they can't police it.
They'd have to watch every single video on the internet,
wouldn't they try and spot it.
So I think you've gotta be quite careful.
Um,
we'll find a way.
All of us,
I think there's,
what we have proven is that people like those sorts of videos and they will
watch them no doubt.
Um,
and we just,
we just have to sort of somewhere within the Patrion,
within the pay wall,
within youtube,
within Vimeo,
within your own Media Player,
within selling the content to existing networks within Netflix,
within southern them to airlines.
You know,
within all of that,
there's a way of making this work.
It just feels like it's taking a long,
long fucking time.
You know,
I've been doing this a long time and you know,
it doesn't really make us any money.
And at the end of the day,
I don't want to get super rich on it,
but it would just be nice for it not to be a lawfully that this year has cost me
money in video and I've made a loss,
a significant loss in video.
And um,
that's kind of shocking.
It's kind of shocking cause you have a huge amount of fans.
You're,
your videos are very popular.
If I type in,
uh,
Chris h a Harris comes up,
you know,
in,
in Youtube,
like on cars like BMW and then I write Chris,
it gives me the option of Harris like immediately it's a very frequently search
term.
Like your videos are very popular.
Uh,
you're one of my favorite all time automotive journalists.
You're very entertaining your fun.
It just doesn't make sense to me that so many people can be enjoying you,
but yet you're having such a hard time figuring out a way to make it financially
profitable that it's actually a loss this year.
I'm just going to bask in the glory of his comments from it.
Um,
the,
uh,
yeah,
it's tough situation and I suppose you can,
what you could do is just sort of lock yourself in a room with a bottle of good
single malt and,
and go,
oh,
woe is me,
and play the violin to yourself.
It'll turn around.
It seems like it can't,
not because the content is there and the audience is there.
It's just a matter of figuring out a way to synchronize money out of a rock.
And I think it's gonna,
it's gonna involve a bit more time and money investment to get to that place.
And I don't have the answer for it,
but I'm not,
as you can tell,
I'm quite careful to,
to answer your,
your phrasing of the drive plus experiment as being a failure.
I don't,
I really don't think it is.
I think I'm going.
Yeah.
And I think,
I think it was a brave move,
um,
but it was actually the only option available to that team of people at that
time.
Um,
and I,
I don't think it was,
I don't think it was crazy at all.
And I and I,
I stressed that it didn't quite work well.
It just didn't work for me at the time and I had to make a call because at the
end of the day,
I am just a sole trader and if I'm hidden behind a pay wall and I'm not being
seen,
that is the biggest problem for me is silence.
Actually.
If I go away for six months and I disappear the Internet,
if it gets you very,
very quickly,
I find,
and I didn't want to be that person that had just disappeared,
it would worry me because I think then to to,
to sort of kickstart yourself again would take even more effort and momentum.
I'm not getting any younger.
I don't quite have the energy I had a few years ago.
I'm feeling that suddenly I'm willing to work crazy hours still,
but I think it just becomes a bit laborious.
And the really sad thing is that we're not talking about,
I'm not talking here about healthcare or something serious like we discussed
earlier.
This is not a social issue.
This is not the third world debt.
We're talking about reviewing fast cars in a way that's actually just roar
entertainment.
It's not a serious business.
It should be about having fun and editorial product is nothing more than the fun
that the people have producing it.
That's what it is.
It's an expression.
It's a vicarious process.
Come and enjoy what we did with this car.
Well that's one of the things that's great about your videos.
You're clearly are having fun.
Well,
you're going sideways around a corner.
You're laughing like a fucking banshee.
It's fine.
It's mega.
But if,
but if you're,
if you're approaching that with a sort of,
Oh god,
this is difficult.
It's costing me too much money,
all the [inaudible],
then you should,
I think you should just pack up and stop it and go and do something else.
Go and grow tomatoes or something.
You just,
you need to stop it.
Um,
and I don't want to get to that stage.
I,
I've,
I love what I do.
It's fucking brilliant fun.
It really is.
It just needs to be sustainable.
And I think we'll get there.
I think in the next year,
my youtube channel,
we'll,
we'll knock along.
Okay.
Well we're going to send some people to you,
Chris Harris on cars.
It's on youtube.
Uh,
we're out of time here man,
but thank you very much.
It's a pleasure meeting you.
Really fun talking to you.
As much fun as I thought it was going to be.
And uh,
thank you so much for all the videos that I've watched over the years,
cause I really enjoy the shit out of him.
Okay.
Thank you very much.
Can we continue it from the driver's seat of your car in about two,
two months time?
Yes,
yes,
for sure.
Good night,
everybody.
Much love big kiss.
See you soon.